and we're live with Dan Aykroyd cutting
oranges and doing a podcast at the same
time yes it's it's kind of like walking
from the the tightrope between two
buildings chewing gum and looking up at
the ceiling have you ever heard of the
the guy who he was a tightrope walker at
the turn of the century and he was very
famous so I forget as he was a French
guy he walked over and I agra falls
several times no a time yeah IIT was a
French tightrope walker and one of the
things he did Joe was one one morning he
said I'm gonna do this but I'm gonna
take my manager on my back I'm gonna
take a small stove and I'm gonna cook
him breakfast in the middle of the falls
right over the falls
oh and this is recorded of him having I
can imagine the manager you know the
conversation there okay you're gonna
climb on my back we're going to the
middle of Falls I'm gonna make you
breakfast I love you I love handling you
but know what really I have to do this
so he took his manager on the back out
to the Falls cooked him eggs right there
and then walked to the other end of the
Falls with a stove his manager all on
his back this is like you know these are
these are feats that that we hear about
did he cook in the middle he cooked in
the middle of the Falls he cooked bit
cooked eggs and I think flapjacks and
all while handling his manager on his
back and handling the stove and the
whole thing yeah there he is there yet
there there there's the manager look oh
my good yeah not funny where's long day
that was his name yeah I want to see him
cooking yeah they must have the photo
they've got a little barrel up there
yeah yeah wheelbarrow he had the manager
on his back ferry as the manager on the
back you see taking him across
yeah that's how you earn you keep as a
manager I know and I don't know I wasn't
there
there he is little table downstairs yeah
so that's where kind of up to here today
and I know I when I came in I saw the
beautiful ball equipment and all your
workout equipment I was going to bring
my pinball gun so I could bounce to them
off your stomach but you know what does
a pinball gun well I'm just making it up
here I know you've got a hard stomach
there and I could just see them bounce
off but and I said you know Joe do you
have a knife for the oranges and I knew
you'd have a really nice sharp hunting
knife and he hauls this out and here
I'll talk a more custom nine beautiful
beautiful where that of I don't know it
was a gift from my friend Donny Vinson
brought it in for me yeah a thousand
people died going over Niagara Falls
many of them suicides and many of them
you know just just that that went over
in rafts and that kid Roger going over
in a life jacket and kids in Bear and
people in barrels who were actually
intending to go over the falls and
wanted to float down that far one dive a
guy and the lifejacket survived and a
couple of them in the barrel survived
but the the tribe of the Niagara Indians
who lived at the indigenous natives who
lived at the bottom of the Falls were
overweight and why were they overweight
because they didn't run through the
forest hunting they took all of the meat
that came through the Niagara River and
went over the falls and was dashed at
the bottom of the falls the Bears the
Wolves the moose all of them who drowned
in the Falls all these was wildlife and
they just harvested the meat off the
rocks at the bottom of the fall how so
they just wait they would just wait
exactly yeah Wow yeah how many things
get stuck it would seem like you'd be
waiting a lot man forty people are here
fall over so every year right now yeah
Wow
oh my god forty but I love upstate New
York I love us I love Niagara Falls New
York's beautiful um architecture from
the 30s and stuff yeah Sonne it's so
neat up there yeah it's a gorgeous part
of the country do you mind if I make a
non-additive vodka drink here for us
yeah this is your vodka company and you
base it I know you are a huge fan of
extraterrestrials and one of the things
I'm very excited to talk to you about is
that but this is about your book for on
all that cool this is based on the
crystal skulls right well the other
package is package is based on the on
the crystal heads because we wanted to
sell the idea of purity and you can see
it's a nice smiling little happy little
skull it was designed by John Alexander
the great Texas artist here's our this
is our wheat version we have corn in
here we have weed in here and there's no
cleaner vodka I must say on the planet
we go to great lengths to make this a
clean product not only is the bottle
beautiful but the unique fluid inside is
what has got us to 70 countries over 50
million bottles sold we've won twelve
old medals we won the producs bow in
Moscow for excellent taste out of 400
beverages and what we do is we take
peaches and cream corn from Chatham
Ontario and we put it in the truck in
the mash and we ship it 95% alcohol
volume at that point and we take it over
and we put it in the ferry boat and we
bring it over at the distillery in
Newfoundland Canada the last one of the
last state-owned stills in the world and
why are we there because the water from
the original Wisconsin glacier is under
Newfoundland so water is an vodkas an
old Russian word for water and really
yeah and great vodkas have sweet water
I'm just gonna I want you to just take a
sip and then I'm gonna make a nice
crystal globe but just so here's our
notes here sir just a sec yeah Cheers
yeah indeed hey to our daughters to
everybody daughters and sons and already
sons daughters mothers it's very good
sweetness sweet vanilla dry crisp with a
kick of heat off the finish our notes
from Anthony Dias blue we take that to
the distillery in Newfoundland we use
the water there we do not add flavor
packs flavor packs are added to lesser
vodkas that's glycerides
sugars terpenes and we put them they put
them in these packages and they put them
into the vodka we eliminated all of that
and we have no additives at all this is
c2h5oh six just absolute ethyl alcohol
grain alcohol purified distilled in in a
carbon filtration system not the one
with the hole is where they just blow it
through no we we distill and we filter
and we pour it over Herkimer diamonds
diamonds yep pour it over diamond we do
we pour it over the Herkimer
semi-precious stone and the Hermit
Apprendi semi-precious stone is a one of
our last purification processes now if
you asked a high school professor what
does pouring alcohol over diamonds do to
the alcohol they probably say well
nothing but our stones after certain
pours a certain number of pours they
turn yellow and we have to bleach them
clean them or replace them the Herkimer
diamond is found in an anomalous area of
upstate New York also in Afghanistan and
in Oaxaca Mexico they're found there
they're little semi-precious
double-ended crystals and people love
the taste of the vodka poured over the
stones now is there
a chemical reaction that causes the
stones to turn yellow or you know again
you know you'd have to sit with a
chemistry professor and say why why does
the alcohol turn that the crystals
yellow is it doing anything as it's
purifying it we've done flavor profiles
where we we pour it over the stones and
give it to people and we don't pour it
over the stones and give it to the
people and they like it better pour it
over the stones now why I like the
Herkimer diamond is of course because
it's near Griffith Air Force Base
Romania and ya know and that was where a
lot of scrambles went up in the 70s and
80s against whatever was coming and
going and in the mountain and the
mountains there Pine Bluff
you know our Pine Bush New York Pine
Bush yeah Pine Bush New York so I
thought this is great Herkimer diamonds
from that area associated with ETS the
Navajo the Aztec the Anasazi they said
that these skulls came down to them from
the star children they were they were
given to them as scrying devices to help
the tribe move forward to give positive
energy to the tribe and so I thought
perfect tie-in we pour our vodka over
Herkimer diamonds were tied in a little
to the extra-terrestrial legend there
with the skull and it kind of it's the
neat kind of bow to our product but the
most important thing is that then though
the fluid in the bottle matches the
beauty of the bottle and the bottle is
to sell the idea of purity and
enlightened thinking enlightened
drinking which was what these these
skulls were made for gosh it's good even
without the orange juice dan Aykroyd you
might be the greatest salesman that's
ever lived another one folks I don't
know if you could see this for people
listening you definitely can't but if
you're looking at it in on YouTube this
is an absolutely gorgeous bottle with
artwork all over it this really cool
design is all his ol skeletons and it's
hard to tell because it's kind of
abstract a lot of the stuff in it but
well that's John Alexander's work he
does he loves skulls and skeletons and
that kind of stuff from the gorgeous and
day of the dead stuff and and so um you
know he he painted that up he's my oh
he's one of my oldest friends and we met
because I work on a Saturday Night Live
and my girlfriend there was Rosie
Schuster one of the writers and you know
we fell in love and we had a great time
and
to show we wrote Fred Garvin male
prostitute and a lot of other things and
then I went away to do Blues Brothers
and she said I'm breaking up with you
and I said whoa for what her for who
well I met this artist John Alexander so
she dumped me for him and now we're best
friends and really what if I go see
again I no no no if she dumped me for
and he went on to uh to get married and
do other stuff but yeah that's how we
met so it's kind of interesting friends
creative friends so we are of the vodka
for the creative spirit it comes from
two artists a writer him an artist a
graphic artist and designer and painter
and sculptor so you know Millennials
love us because there's a no BS story on
our purity we are we are we are a pure
story we're a story about fun and about
enlightened drinking in moderation of
course and we are a story about quality
and so I think people are buying we have
a lot of female demographic there
because of the cleanliness because we
don't have the additives in it and you
know we just take the trouble to make
this product in a special way and we do
this about 11 years we're in 70
countries and I'm doing doing really
really well with it
because people are getting the story
that it's not only the bottle it's it's
what since what's in the bottle you get
at BevMo
total wines ABC liquor bars all over the
the world have it now and yeah they got
a sign bomb they like the they like the
no no additive story and you know it's
you know it's a little more expensive in
retail but it works out to about 37
cents a drink more if you have 25 drinks
in a bottle you buy that bottle it's you
know you're paying a little more for the
quality and for the package but you got
a you don't have to yet you don't have
to pay too much more for for a drink
it's like 37 cents more if the average
drink Wynn bars we say we sell it for
like maybe seven bucks a shot or say now
in bucks a shot seven four or took you
know two for 14 and 3 for 21 while
losing people in the weeds here this is
a very delicious though I'm not a vodka
guy I generally like whiskey because I
like to know what's happening I think
about vodkas it's so smooth and this is
very delicious and smooth like before
you know what you're [ __ ] up well
I feel like you know it with every taste
where you like oh we don't have an
overdose Casa T it's sweet and and and
that's it's got beautiful viscosity
though this is the thing to drink around
a ketogenic diet do you can you want to
want a little citrus in there try it
sure yes your move yeah yeah no I like I
liked it get can you squeeze it in there
very slowly and make it look like an egg
yolk going in there and I'm having a lot
of fun with it the business it's 11
years we're having fun we're fighting
against the big guys you know we got to
do stunts and do exciting things and
talk you know talk about it in ways that
it hasn't been talked about before the
we did change the industry we are the
purest play out there in terms of a
vodka consumption I don't slag other
brands they want to use the flavor
packages they want to put glyceride in
there which is of course since that it's
a lipid you want to put in them there
it's a cousin to antifreeze I gotta say
glyceride glycerol but if you're like
the whole person your cousins a murderer
though does that matter well let me see
Christ you know love prisoners and
Christ forgave so it's Gandhi's sister I
don't know yeah maybe she's a nice
person I want to talk to you about the
the story of the crystal skulls
themselves cuz there's this strange sort
of folklore attached to them and then
there's a lot of people that believe
that it's all horseshit and that these
were created by modern people and buried
underground yep in order to well my
understanding of it is there you go yeah
and indeed that's just as the citrus
model the crystal driver there were 13
heads and and it was purported that the
Navajo Anasazi the Mayans the Aztecs
each had one the most famous one is the
the mitchell-hedges skull which was
found on the Yucatan by Anna Mitchell
hedges he reached into a cave she was
with her grandfather and was around 1926
and she reached in and there was an oil
cloth covered item in there and she
pulled it out and opened it up and there
was the two-piece detachable jaw
mitchell-hedges skull beautiful skull
the hewlett-packard engineers did a test
on it in the 60s they said it could not
have been carved by a lapidary by my
tools it had to have been polished over
hundreds of years over over centuries to
get to the shape that it was
they said it was a polished item let's
see there's the mitchell-hedges skull
the Phyllis Newman skull named max she
says doesn't that later decided by some
people this was not okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna exactly get to that point because
of course it's it's important it doesn't
affect my business whether they're fake
or not these were beautiful artifacts
and we've recreated it beautifully but
it's nice to know the true story and I
have a kind of a thought on the theory
either way so there's the Phyllis Newman
skull named max she has to put it in the
closet because it talks to her there's
no way we hit the brakes
Felicity hit the brakes bunch of you
you're an excellent talker sir oh well
you know I was inoculated with a
gramophone needle at birth I could talk
a taxi dispatcher into vow of silence I
could talk an air-raid siren to scrap
but and you're obviously Canadian
because you said slag yeah Canadian gal
she of the tall so that's another
tangent Canadian gals and yes an ATM
guys so the Philip Newman Newman skull
she she got it it's name is Mac she has
to put it in the closet because it talks
to her she said so there's the
mitchell-hedges yes she does
Phyllis has that one then there's the
there's the mitchell-hedges skull that's
in Indiana the woman the man that took
care of Anna at the end of her life
eventually had it and got it it sat in
grafton ontario for many years and i
never saw it but people said when they
walked into the room and she uncovered
it with the cloth she kept it in that
there was an immediate feeling of
well-being and healing coming over to
look at the at the original
mitchell-hedges skull there's one in
Mexico City it's one of like one of our
minis it's got a cross stuck right in
the top of it which is you know that
would shatter crystal if you did that
how that cross got there I don't know
there are there's one of the Smithsonian
in Washington too at Smithsonian
Washington DC and one of the Victoria
and Albert Museum so that's there's
supposed to be eight that we have in
five that we're missing the woman that
Smithsonian who has the two there I
think it's they're a cloudy orange one
on a cloudy green one and they're
smaller she says they're all fakes that
they were carved by a German lapidary in
the 1800s and that he seeded them around
the world oh wait a minute I think one
was found in Tibet one was found in Ohio
we're hearing at the Serpent Mound why
does she think this one gentleman did
he because he was an expert lapidary he
had the tools to do it and and she
figures her theory is that they're not
artifacts polished by tribal hands and
passed down that they're all fakes but
it's just wait a minute he would have
had to about an airship to go and
deposit these wherever they might be
around the world and what pictures of
the skulls up the smithsonian personal
heads and millions crystal heads you can
get in victoria albert crystal head do
they all have the same similar type of
markings there there's the there's
there's yes yes they do they do they all
have the same now you see some of them
are more are clearer see there's one of
the the the the British Museum and
there's some that are clear and they're
more beautiful and there's some that are
rougher like that one there and then and
the green and the orange one but she
says all fakes but if they're all fakes
how did they get to these different
places around the world and how were
they found well here's the thing but
what why fake the word fake is very
strange because it's like they are
certainly real carved crystal skulls
were they from tribal ancestry them is
the question who made the modern Western
and Hell where they polished over they
car if that's the thing aren't they
beautiful oh god what are the indigenous
people say they say they found them
there now the whole say they came from
the star children that they they were
brought down and deposited and given to
them as crystal ball devices crying
devices - what's that one down there
Jamie keeps growing where you were the
one on the left right there that looks
somewhat almost like a real skull oh
Israel's yeah no the green is beautiful
so so I guess I don't know I'm not a
scientist I'm not a professional
historian I guess I have to trust the
lady at the Smithsonian but then I
questioned they were found at different
times in history around the world how do
you go and seed how do you deposit them
there why did she believe that is she
given a coherent reason why she thinks
that they're all hoaxes or she's done
their analysis whatever they've done you
know - through their skulls but again
the youlet packard engineers took that
mitchell-hedges skull and they they said
this cannot be have not had been
polished it would have been cracked or
destroyed it could not have been built
by tools it would have been cracked or
destroyed it it had to have been
polished
yeah so but what about some sort of a
very fast-moving drill with a diamond
bid on it that can slowly grind down
well that would be then that would be
them the remarks that would be visible
under under the scanner they put hood
and you polish those marks down I don't
I think that the intensity of this of
the Hewlett Packard scrutiny revealed
that there were no none of those marks
and that's why they were able to make
this here's the problem with this it's
like you want them to be real don't you
oh yeah I do too I get to but I don't
trust me no neither do I so that's why I
say openly when you're saying all these
things I want to believe you I want them
to be from the sky people mm-hmm I do
too but again you know you've got a
professional in Washington at our
National Museum there who says no no
yeah well what does she know well we
could go might be her name we should get
her on the first get her on the phones
might be a party-pooper
well I eyes I think that she's probably
as in love and in love with the skulls
even though they are you know not
polished it in her mind I bet she loves
them as much as we do but the thing is
if you are a professional intellectual
or someone as a curator of you know fine
artwork and ancient relics you kind of
have to be one of those people that
dismisses anything preposterous because
if not that's right like Neil Tyson
don't you love us I love him I love Neil
lovin but he there's no way you can sit
down and say Neil Barney and Betty Hill
were abducted by a flying saucer in 1957
he's not going to accept right because
he can't accept that because everything
in his training everything in his
knowledge everything that he knows about
physics and science and propulsion in
the universe and how to get from place
to place defies the defies the legend or
I would say defies the theory that there
are extraterrestrial advanced ships out
there he can't accept it it's just you
know he it would be unprofessional for
him to say okay there's even a
possibility that there were abductions
but the Betty and Barney Hill story is
very interesting but there's there's no
real evidence other than their
testimonies that correct well there was
a stain on Betty's dress
there's her excellent recall she was not
he was on one stain on her dress that's
so interesting
it was a fluid that they used in
in in the testing that some kind of a
fluidity in testing that that they did
it wonder they drew over from her and
they drew sperm oh yeah from him now so
there's a book out called contact by
Stanton Friedman we read that yeah and
Kathleen yep I'd love to know where the
car is were they the the Chevy they were
driving or where I don't know I'd have
to ask Kathleen where it is did they get
it end up on a junkyard since there were
marks on the back of the car as well
there were trace evidence in the back of
the car you know Ted Phillips is he goes
around the world collecting trace Ella
evidence and radioactive signatures from
sightings and and and landings on the
back of the car there was a couple of
marks but it was Betty's it's their
credibility why would they want to bring
this into their lives and she was
conscious a semi-conscious through much
of it and Barney was not conscious he
was unconscious if you hear the tapes of
Ben Simon's interviews with them under
Elsa screaming and the and he was just
so frightened
yeah and that's and the Zeta Reticuli
map when when a little the being Betty
looked at the map and the being shorter
a map if she was on her way out the door
and she said may I take this in the
being was going to give it to her but
then another one zipped up and said no
you can't have this reticula is exactly
the same place where Bob Lazar says they
found those the with the spaceships that
they have an area as for well the little
greys Zeta Reticuli Barney and Betty's
abduction you had Marjorie fish
inanimate your amateur astronomer she
took the memory of Betty's Betty drew up
the star map and she did a
three-dimensional scale model of that
part of the universe and was able to
identify Zeta Reticuli
1 & 2 and accepted by astronomers so
that map that Betty saw aboard that ship
had not been seen on earth before and
petty has no history of astronomy no no
studying no none of it at all and and
and you know interesting things like
when they got back to the the house
there there there the house was open and
the keys to the house were in on the
table with leaves so that they might
have dropped them at the site and the
beings returned them now you know who
Ted Budd Hopkins was yes he said that
since um he studied the Linda Cortile
case where the woman was floated out of
her
and building over the East River and
orange orb picked her up Tellez
he was the God was an artist he was a
graphic artist he was a designer a
painter and a lovely man and he was one
of the first people to start to deal
with the trauma of abductees he got a
reputation for me able to interview them
hypnotize them interview them and get
their stories and empathize and
sympathize with them and he said that in
some cases that he studied the beings
would grab a man from somewhere in
America
and grab a woman and out of their cars
out of their clothes put him up test
them draw over draw sperm fluids
whatever they were doing and then the
woman would wake up in the man shoes
or a different car or the almost as if
that the beings were finished with them
I don't care where they go now yeah I
put him put him back you know that kind
of thing he said that was the oddest
phenomena like releasing a trout yeah
that's right well I think that's such a
trout you catch a big rainbow trout in
your fly-fishing and you got a barbless
hook you know most people if you go to
Montana go to the Gallatin River shout
out to the Gallup beautiful gorgeous
place mmm people catch and release
because they they appreciate that the
trout are there they'd rather go by
halibut from a store and not eat the
fish because they want this the salmon
to be healthy they want the trout to be
healthy well so they catch them and then
they release them but if you're a brown
trout brown trout or invasive but if
you're a saint here oh you're a rainbow
trout and someone catches you and you
know they take you on some 200 yard run
down this river as they're trying to
draw you and it's a big 9 pound rainbow
catch of a lifetime you're a full time
and some guy pulls it on it takes
pictures of it like shows it and then
releases it and then this thing's like
how the [ __ ] did I get here what am i
doing outside of my universe yeah am i
doing in this other dimension of air
where I can't breathe it precisely yeah
yeah and that's that's what that's
catcher Moses lease with people Travis
Walton says you know you got to think of
them as just people from over there fire
in the sky movie was based on here's
another interesting story here's what I
want people read ability there and
credibility with Barney and Betty I just
don't think they're lying and I don't
think the aerial schoolchildren are
lying I don't want to think they're
lying this is the problem that I have
with it I want to believe them
but this is what I want people to
consider because most people that are
pragmatic
people that don't want to be ridiculed
they look at these stories then go out
come on people are full of [ __ ] and I've
been there too
but I want I want people to imagine that
if if aliens did a que occasionally
visit earth what how often do you think
this would take place and how it would
be very infrequently and if it was if it
was happening these would be completely
unique unusual occurrences out of
nowhere where someone would come down
they would do something and they would
be leaving the person with this thought
in this memory and this inability to
describe it with normal words if you
were taken aboard a spaceship and you
were some reptilian beings that were
three feet tall were running experiments
on you and you were paralyzed then they
released you back on earth how what
words do you have available to you to
describe this experience in a way they
like if you tell me hey Joe I went
whitewater rafting with my kids it was a
great time it was so fun we got to see
Eagles and it was it was gorgeous and
then we had lunch at this beautiful
little cafe what a great day I can
envision this experience I can see it
but if you tell me hey man we went
camping and I woke up and some alien at
a finger of my gosh the allagash
incident they went camping and they they
were they destroyed a few of those right
there's hundreds of thousands and here
this is I brought you a book this is
Bruce Maccabees book it's all the
headlines from 1950 to 432 reports given
and I'll address your specific question
about people how they relate their
experiences and and how genuine they
feel in a second here 432 reports given
the Air Force in 1952 on aerial
sightings ships from other planet we've
got memories members memos from the
government here former army pilots these
Flying Saucer by daylight whatever was
sighted here July 30 stories fighter
pilots at Newcastle stay alert for more
saucer reports these are newspaper yeah
that's yours well newspapers never lie
well uh why don't you know that well
they never they never make fake stories
well I never touched a New York Times
pretty reliable Ralph Blumenthal and
Leslie Kean are reporters for the New
York Times and they've been studying
this phenomenon they report were very
credibly on it
tell you how an abductees experience is
related I attended a lecture at the
Fifth Avenue Medical Institute in
Manhattan with my wife a few years ago
that would be about 15 years ago and
John Mack was a lecturer you know he
wrote the book abduction he was the
Harvard psychiatrist who wrote abduction
we can get that up to abduction John
Mack yes I've read that as well yeah and
so I freaked a friend of mine out she
was a very pragmatic non UFO believing
person and she could we were working
together on Newsradio my friend more
attorney and she came up to me and she
goes like this book is freaking me the
[ __ ] out and he wrote a second book as
well didn't he died in a car accident
John Mack believed he died in a car
accident stepped off a curb in in in in
a small town in England and he was
struck by a car yeah and three other
John Max died the same day in England so
so you Pete think people whack and John
Max does he know too much I don't know
say again I was at this lecture and
there were 300 abductees there that that
some of you we interviewed with some
some he had not but who were therefore
interested to find out about more about
their experience and one guy got up and
said he had one arm and I don't know
whether that was related I don't think
was related to the experience but he
said I'm a Wall Street broker I'm quite
well-off I have a sailboat I was in Long
Island Sound a few years ago and a blue
light hit me and I had missing time of
about five or six hours but in it I have
felt filtrated memories of beings
addressing me and telling me that I was
powerful and influential and I could
help the planet survive and they put me
back on my ship and I woke up and and
and and he said I'm waiting for them to
come back I want them to come back and I
asked the room I got up and I said of
all of you who've been taken how many of
you would would want to repeat the
experience or have it happen again and
about half of them said no no way they'd
wanted to have and I have it happen
again and a half said yeah we'd like to
have yeah yeah half yeah now I love of
so Bruce sign this to me and I'm going
to give it to you and it just got great
it's got great headlines from the you
know from the 50s which was a massive
time for saucers you know that famous
for all the saucers over the
the capital the glowing lights and yeah
see if you can find that photo Jim's
question ein 252 Washington lighting
this was initiated by the detonation of
the atomic bombs at Hiroshima and
Nagasaki where they decided okay these
[ __ ] monkeys are doing some stupid
[ __ ] we need to go down there and see
what's up and see if there's eminent
danger to the cosmos let's find out what
kind of capabilities they have because
if you listen to Lazar or if you believe
the work of zecharia sitchin or any of
the people that believe that human
beings were engineered that there's the
the reason why this is giant leap
between us and the rest the primates on
the planet is because something came
down and manipulated our genetics well
the movie mission to Mars with Tim
Robbins you know basically it says that
you know basically it spits shows the
face on Mars and that that is one of
NASA employees favorite movies yeah
there they are
yeah 1952 UFO incident thank you come on
let's go here and that's crazy
yeah then in an airplane that ain't a
helicopter now some crazy photograph and
it's from 1952 I mean the the special
effects back then were incredibly crude
no no this is something that was
reported thousands of people they Jake
scrambled jets from from Andrews Fortner
as well as the Phoenix lights those
Phoenix lights is fascinating these you
know the Fife Symington the governor
said I saw them he made fun of it with
an alien nut yeah but he dummies about
that afterwards yeah I was put under
pressure to do so yeah he's in a movie
called what is it there's a there's a
documentary on Netflix it's available
that he's in that he talks about the
pressure that they put on him to make
light of that incident and he talks
about his own personal experiences with
seeing something some sort of triangle
shaped craft that was enormous the size
of several football fields it was flying
overhead that was completely silent and
how it freaked him out
angle the triangle and Delta crafts are
very very interesting but you know the
the Tinley Park incidents of the of the
80s and with Sammy Rondo was the
investigator there for new fun these
things would park over the family
barbecue for about half an hour and you
know families and suburbs were looking
up them the sky being blotted out by
these things parking above them
so yeah I think it comes down to they I
don't think these beings I well Lord
Hill Norton said there were 23 different
species visiting the planet in 23
different types of ships I don't think
they want a formal relationship with
people on earth they want an informal
secret relationship I think they
probably have one with elements of the
black elements of the Air Force and the
government you know David Sarita is I've
heard his David Sarita you should have
him on he's very knowledgeable about
this
he's his theory is that the Roswell
event may have been precipitated by the
Trinity explosion at because it was such
an interdimensional disturbance of the
atoms being split and that explosion
that was there was that that saucer
there that went down in 47 may have may
have been influenced somehow negatively
by by that explosion now Stanton
Friedman doesn't didn't buy that
I love Stanton he just passed away there
he was the expert on Roswell
yeah I'm upset that I never got to meet
him before he died he was so credible
interesting guy who believe in UFOs but
believe most people were not were lying
about them oh really
really yeah well he believed that there
was a lot of horseshit
going on including Bob Lazar he thought
Bob Lazar was full of [ __ ] well I again
why would why would Bob go out there and
do that and and and compromise his life
let me tell you something after talking
to him for three hours and then riding
with him the night before my I don't
have I don't is to believe I had the
best [ __ ] meter in the world but as
I've gotten older I've gotten more
honest and I don't I didn't see anything
he's he's incredibly smart guy and he's
not a guy who's like seeking out
attention and he's not profiting from
this and that just his demeanor and
everything Jesus he's like an accountant
he's a legitimate scientist yeah I mean
and I've talked to him one of the things
that I engaged him with we had dinner we
talked about science just science in
general and we talked about all sorts of
different things and he's a scientist
he's a legit scientist I've talked to a
lot of them yeah I know what kind of
person he has he said and they just
hassled him again there they raided his
his nuclear like to think he has element
115 that's what they think wouldn't they
all love to have that yeah that's what
they think that's some artist created
that thing up there with element 115
yeah element 115 indeed well there's
this little sliver of that yeah
that's would be pretty exciting they he
talked openly about it in the 90s that
he had managed to weasel some away from
the area s4 and they think that he still
has it yeah there was some experiments
that he had done that George Knapp had
actually filmed that it showed some
really bizarre distortions using this
stuff and then it was able to it was
there was I got to remember exactly what
it did that they show but they did some
experience with like steam or smoke or
something like that where they showed
element 115 emitting some sort of vapor
well no it was emitting some sort of a
field oh yeah literally couldn't
physically touch this stuff mm-hmm
yeah no would it be nice to find that
that's for sure but I believe I believe
Bob I do and I believe Barney and I
believe Travis I want to believe all of
them I believe the I believe the
allagash guys why would why would they
do this [ __ ] well I love to lie they
love attention they love crazy stories
people love telling you their psychic
people love believing in astrology
people but people believe in Bigfoot I
think that there's a lot of people out
there that want fantastic things to be
real including me it's exciting it's way
more exciting than generally than not
being it is entertaining that's what I
love the whole stuff it's my problem
with the thing is that these people were
severely damaged like Barney Hill was
damaged the Allagash Boys were damaged
Travis Walton were dumped
psychologically damaged by these by
these experiences allegedly you don't
know I mean they've damaged already this
might have been except that yeah this
might have been somebody you read
contact and Betty interviewed doesn't
she come off as she does someone who was
extremely credible she does she does so
does Barney the Betty and Barney Hill
it's a they're an interesting couple
because they were an interracial couple
what year was this this had 57 so they
were dealing with all sorts of pressure
this is during the civil rights movement
and they were you know some you know
they were pretty it was it was not the
what you would expect for people that
were calling out and trying to get
attention and the way I'm you know the
way they described this it resonated
with people well he was having
nightmares and rashes in him they had to
come to some medical conclusion about it
and that's our friend consistent the
story was extremely it wasn't they they
consulted a friend at the air
force you know who they knew and they
they came to bend Simon on that no it's
it's a fascinating story there's this
you know it's it's just it's just in a
way as again it's it's it's very very
very entertaining and how did you get
involved in this well my mother worked
for the Ministry of munitions and supply
in World War two for the minister and
she was suborn to work with the aircraft
production for the hurricane she was in
charge of working with getting the
hurricane fuselages built in Canada for
that he for the hurricane fighter plane
so she was you know in the world of
aviation and in 1947 she was walking
down sparks street in Ottawa and she
looked up in the sky and she was sort of
said something told me to look up and
she said she saw what looked like a
Christmas tree ornament just winking
above the street about four or five
hundred feet winking on and off red
green white red green light and she
thought that's odd you know and then she
looked at and she just zipped off in the
sky and disappeared and around the house
after that point we always had articles
there's an article there's a cover of
Life magazine with Marilyn Monroe talked
about flying saucers as a cover look
magazine with Elizabeth Taylor it get
catalogs the Barney and Betty Hill
incident so whenever one of those
articles come up she always had that at
home for me to read so I've kind of I
was interested it from from then and
I've had four sightings myself quite
vivid the first one was in Martha's
Vineyard I was four in the morning I got
up to take a leak on the balcony there
and I looked up in the sky and about a
hundred thousand feet up I saw two
glowing disks flying an echelon
formation you saw this I saw this I will
do I was was I'm in my thirties yeah and
so I look up and I see these things and
they're moving man they're going from
Horizon to Horizon twenty thousand miles
an hour and I I've been in an f5 I've
had it in my hands I've been in a b25 I
know helicopters I know aviation I know
meteoric Bowl rides I know what's not a
meteor and what is I know what's a
helicopter and what is I know it's the
moon and Venus two glowing glowing round
objects a hundred thousand feet maybe
twenty thousand miles an hour they do
and because they went across the sky
like just in a zigzag formation so if I
screamed to my wife my friends they got
up the three of us saw it and I said you
know and they all knew it was something
unusual that was my first sighting okay
now who knows
okay meteoric ball ride though many
people can dispute that that wasn't real
but I I know what I saw I know what my
friend saw or my wife saw those things
were moving they were glowing fast they
were flying in formation and they were
doing enough speed to get from basically
the right side of my eyes to the left
side of my eyes really fast the second
one was I was I was in so that's so
that's four I count those two is two and
then the second one that I saw so the 1
2 the third one I saw I was up I was in
Montreal Canada and I was at the 23rd
floor of the Queen Elizabeth hotel and
this would have been when we were doing
patron in Canada the Patron tequila a
promotion and that was a bitumen in the
early 2000s and and I looked up and
beyond the window there and I saw this
well it just looked like an air mattress
turned over on its you know with with it
with the bubbles on the bottom it was
huge it was a hundred 50 feet long 50
feet wide gray it was a gray rainy day
in Montreal broad daylight and here was
this thing at the 23rd story of the
hotel and I'm looking at it and it moves
slowly down on st. Catherine Street and
I'm thinking where are the wires where
the wires were it's got to be a balloon
it's got to be there's no Thanksgiving
Day Parade here what what is that and my
friends are with me what is that and it
come along and just parked outside the
window we looked at it big grey thing
with these bulbs underneath and then it
slowly turned and we saw the full length
of it and then it went around the corner
we ran out on the hall and we just
watched a drift kind of sideways off
over the st. Lawrence River and
disappear
wha-ha-ha you know do people take
pictures no we didn't get any pictures
and I don't know who else all yours is
in the two thousand let's see five or
six something like that and then that
other people report it no I don't know I
should think I should have checked in
and seen in Montreal with the local
MUFON I think they have a representative
up there but it was
we all saw it and then they the fourth
one that I saw I was on my motorcycle
leavin town to go at Kingston Ontario
where I lived there and I was driving
out of the farm gate and and I saw
there's a power line that runs on the
opposite farm there across the road and
I saw this winking red light just moving
slowly along the top of the power pylons
and I thought well you know helicopters
did do that kind of work where they were
they string power lines but they don't
really do it at night I thought that's
got to be a chopper or a hydro chopper
like a hydro company chopper watching
the powerlines checking for faults or I
don't know Ives and it goes along like
this and I'm watching it and I stopped
the bike you know on I'm on and then it
stops and makes a right angle turn and
comes right at me and so I turn on the I
have a police motorcycle so I turn on my
wig wags you know like that you have a
police motorcycle cars why do you know a
policeman have a police aquit well are
you a cop awkward imagine getting pulled
over by a blues brother wouldn't that be
good I've actually I've actually had the
experience of actually pulling some
people about any pulled people over
sure why'd you pull him over your
sheriff's well I was a reserve deputy
sheriff for Taunton I was a reserve the
reserve I must say but I served under
the first african-american Sheriff and
Hinds County Mississippi in its history
anyway back to my sighting the thing
comes along I put on the wig wags and
the bike and it stops above me and it
turns on a light and I'm going where's
the rotor whop where's the where's the
wash where's it come on a helicopter at
3,000 feet you can hear it this thing's
like three four hundred feet above me
and I'm looking at the thing I'm
thinking where's the wash where's the
words that it looks like it looks like a
helicopter it's got to be a helicopter
do I see a canopy do I see rings rotors
nothing just just a mass of kind of
metallic and lights and it just shines
this light light on me and I turned the
lights on the bike on and and then turn
them off and then it winked the light
off and it just drifted out over the
field and just drifted off like that hmm
so so you've had three different and
then one night well one night I was in
bed I was a night in bed with my wife it
was in the nineteen eighty seven or so
and I well I woke bolt upright at 3 in
the morning I said I'd kind of go
outside I got to go outside they're
calling me they're calling me they want
me to see they want me to see
she says all go back to sleep so I went
back to sleep next day all over the
radio of upstate New York
they talked about a big pink spiral in
the sky that had appeared to upstate
northern northeastern Ontario in upstate
New York and they were saying oh it was
a Chinese rocket what at a bottle rocket
or the Chinese Center rocket this was
the explanation that the media and the
government was giving at the time so
thought those are my experiences and you
know how yeah and then and then an
interesting thing same thing happened
well I was doing a show called out there
beyond belief and we were doing it over
there for for Bonnie hammer over there
at at the sci-fi channel and it was an
interview show where I talked to Doug
Meldrum the Sasquatch expert and and all
kinds of talk to Doug yeah I believe him
I believe him he's passionate about it I
don't see why he's also a scientist I
talked to all those people but the day
that I had sasquatches are real yes I do
I believe I believe that there's got to
be that's just you know Gabrielle Reece
the Olympian sure have you she talked
about her Sasquatch experience no now I
need to talk yeah you're really yeah
yeah he's so gigantic and beautiful I
would imagine that Sasquatch wanted to
breed well that's why apparently it
shook a camper that was she she was up
in an upstate woman super athlete she
was attacked her camper was attacked by
one she tells that story yeah but where
was I about the I was where we go back
to the Gabrielle Reece a squatcher by
how you interviewed all kinds of people
on this show
I haven't heard anything about my show I
was supposed to be a let's watch it was
supposed to be a yeah but was supposed
to be a show I saw on sci-fi channel an
interview show where I'd interviewed
everybody you know all the people in the
in the field of cryptozoology in that
and and and sci-fi and and and science
fiction and theory and UFOs and I had
Steven Greer and Steven Bassett on that
same to have that Steven Greer on the
show too okay so I interview Steven
Bassett I'm about to interview Greer and
I get a call in about like noon at our
noon break and they call and they say
your shows cancelled we won't get out of
the studio by the end of the day
we're not gonna air anything that you've
done sleeve and career Steven Bassett
Steven Greer the UFO show it gets
canceled that day
now maybe miss hammer made a decision
you know talk shows aren't really our
thing or Ackroyd's not really what we
want on a network or I don't know what
she called by someone or what why that
day when I was going to do this vivid
you know UFO show that was going to go
out on the on the air eventually why why
then did it get canceled those problems
how are the well no we never got we
never got to air I did 26 of them and
never got there never got to air so you
just filmed them and it never did you
guys do any wacky ones where they got
the film and like what are these crazy
[ __ ] doing was there any of that
like if you were non-believer non UFO
enthusiast your interview show I didn't
show any footage I just I just interview
just talk to people yeah so the day of
my UFO showed I was going to my big
Steven Greer and Steven batchat show he
got cancelled so you know there's that
do you think that they would can't
listen sci-fi is all about those shows I
mean I watched an episode of sci-fi
where there's a bunch of people that
claim to be trapped in a cabin in Maine
because werewolves were outside it's
just like it's kinda nuns they don't do
talk shows I did a show on sci-fi show
called Joe Rogan questions everything
well how long it lasts not very long but
part of that was my idea
uh whatever body keep do it worked for
Bonnie hammer know it was different
people better than she's one of the
smartest executives in the industry and
I I don't doubt that she'll be running
NBC someday or all of Universal but I
know and I just I just I would all like
to know what happened did someone call
you Bonnie in and say you know don't
bring myself I don't no one's gonna call
people about UFOs I mean if they're
gonna make phone calls they're gonna you
know take out Don Lemon or something
because he talks [ __ ] about Trump just
doesn't make sense
I was like to know what UFOs are openly
discredited by normal people people not
industry so half the world it believes
if you look at the work of Ralph
Blumenthal and Leslie Kean New York
Times reporters they're credibly
reporting these to this stuff Barney and
Betty Hill the state of New Hampshire
has certified their site there there
has certified their experience with a
plaque you can go to the place where
they were allegedly abducted in the
state of New Hampshire has UFO canceled
know that that doesn't mean anything
doesn't mean it happened means it's a
state certified or state recognized
paranormal experience sure you can get
anything certified in New Hampshire
that's a goofy place well I don't have
to shout out to New Hampshire but I'm
sad ler comes from there that's one of
my he's a he's a definitely a national
trend that great Wow
like a state certified and also another
state service are 161 out rising right
around the time that was a couple months
before Kennedy was shot right wasn't
shot in November
63 for him right yeah Oh was it 63 yeah
63 and that wasn't 47 yeah but there you
go there Barney Hill experienced a close
encounter with an unidentified and then
in Marfa Texas you heard of the Marfa
lights no I have no now the Marfa lights
are these anomalous and that's a state
kind of recognize paranormal mystery too
mysterious Marfa lights they have a kind
of a picnic area we can watch them at
night no one knows what they are they
appear every night and they bounce
around on the horizon they go up and
down and back and forth people sell
their headlights from different cars in
the highway but the Air Force the state
police they've all tried to figure out
what they are and they just don't know
what the Marfa lights are and they're
recognized by the state of Texas as a
paranormal event yes I do yeah lightning
is a real thing that's created by
pressure inside the tectonic plates but
every night consistently going north and
symmetrical pattern but I mean every
night we go there tonight
yes helmet yes we could hundred percent
absolutely really yep Marfa lights how
many videos of the Marfa lights are
available are Fayette Martha there they
are you see we got here what do we got
here yeah
no one knows well rednecks they're
driving their trucks over there well
that's what they say they've looked in
there they've done surveys they've done
geodetic surveys what is it is it gas is
it what what do they think it is what's
the official explanation the no one
knows mystery lights that state of Texas
has a little plaque the Marfa mystery
lights enjoy them because they're there
they're gonna be there tonight those
sings p.m. to 2:00 in the morning
really
every night everybody and we get a place
out there every night smoke weed and
stare at the sky do you is there any UFO
sightings that you think are nonsense
is there any like mainstream ones that
you listen to and you're like I'm not
buying that one um well um all the
people that I've talked to that have had
sightings and have that experienced it
seemed very genuine I don't know that
anyone has been I don't know anyone
that's been blown out publicly that I
would doubt I mean can you think of one
I don't know I believe like the allagash
boys Calvin Parker down there in
Mississippi the Pascagoula incident I
mean again their their lives were
severely negatively affected by these
experiences but they didn't know whether
or not that was gonna be the case when
they reported on it a lot of people do
silly things that negatively affect
their life yeah and this they don't
they're not a way they don't they're not
future tellers there's a there's a guy
there he was he says that the alien
appeared at his back screen porch door
he's in Colorado do you know that
gentleman he says that your balls deep
in this man you know all these stores
this guy I don't really I don't know if
I believe him because no yeah Colorado
of alien at the backdoor or I don't know
one seam right I just looked I don't
know if I believe him or not it just
looked like he was fabricating there I'm
sure there's a lot of people fabricating
things and I'm also sure there's a lot
of people that believe they're telling a
true story but in fact or schizophrenic
or they have some issues or there's I
think there's a lot of that going on
billy meier was was doubted for sure
what do you think about him the pictures
are so vivid and the platings play team
story so vivid I don't I don't I mean a
book Billy Meyer you can see early Meyer
UFO photos so where's he from
he sweats he was a swiss yeah we have
his book that was that I know somebody
came to the Comedy Store and Blamey does
a book on that kind of pictures on that
yeah well look at the one by the pine
tree they're going they're going all he
attached the saucer to the pine but he
threw it in the air and took a picture
of it okay well that's one theory but
wasn't it you know didn't they do that
just to show the scale of their ship and
some of those photos are pretty pretty
convincing I don't know and
okay if you want to say who keeps taking
awesome pictures use those I'm not
buying it well again you know if there
was anyone that I had doubt because
thrown so much doubt has been thrown his
way
that's pretty I mean how do you
well I suppose with Photoshop but Bruce
Maccabee I believe is Bruce macabees
analyzed these well he wrote this book
he says they're real right but a guy
who's writing a book on UFOs is
analyzing you know what you're saying
they're real there's no but bonnets the
Bruce Maccabee is a doctor and he's
society he said he worked for the Naval
Air I want to talk to his
ex-girlfriend's see if he's full of [ __ ]
so you know I'm saying like like you
could say all these positive things
beyond he was he worked for the Navy he
was the one he's the expert well he's
the expert he said yes the Gucci version
yeah look at those balls well it's a
bling-bling those are the pin balls oh
yeah well if you had an Instagram
account you an alien that's the one
you'd but I think he did a photo he did
a photo analysis and he said that that
Bruce believes they're real and I
believe Bruce of you if you read this
book here he said he's the real thing
like what Stanton was the real thing
Bruce Maccabee is the real thing because
they're there scientists who are doing
you know very very thorough and close
inquiry on the on the matter so if you
ask me who I doubt maybe I don't know
Billy Meyer I don't know I don't know
yeah he took too many yeah if you had
like three like a glut it's like yeah
it's chocolate yeah come on bro that's
all you're doing
you're out there and they just come to
you why don't you set up a camera crew
24/7 for a couple weeks and a little
Steven Greer uses lasers he points them
up to the sky and and kind of attracts
them yeah daughters have said that if
you know they've sat out and watched
these things come and go with in North
Carolina at their house but people
saying that something happened and so
how about all the photos but his thing
is about UFOs he's made documentaries
about UFOs business is he knows a lot
about UFOs what do you walk to Greer I'm
not buying what you want is you want the
Sam you want the you want the herb
Shermer story
what's the herb Shermer story Nebraska
Highway patrolman on patrol sees a flash
of light in the Ashland oil refinery
near Murat Nebraska flash of light and
oil refinery in the broad daylight not
thing could be a fire goes up not into
UFOs highway patrolman goes up he was
taken into a ship and deposit and he's
one of the famous one so no agenda there
I didn't want to tell a story and got
into trouble flow and here's the third
Shermer herb sage i rmer no disrespect
to her but some cops are crooked they
steal people's money some cops rape
people some cops pull people over for
nothing some people shoot people for
non-existing crimes a lot of there's a
lot of people that just happen to be
police officers that are also full of
[ __ ] that's that a lot of people are
foolish yep that's true but I you know
again here he is is a guy why would he
say that's not the other one is his
evidence
well his evidence is anecdotal like a
lot of it but that's the problem
well the Phoenix the Phoenix lights
there's there's video of that that's a
different one that's a different wana
Zamora Zia is a mor a he was a New
Mexico Highway patrolman he said a
saucer landed he saw it land and Dan
Aykroyd everybody wants to be special
and one of the best ways to be special
is for you to have a special moment with
some special creatures from a special
place no one else can recognize whether
or not you're telling the truth or not
telling the truth right talk about this
and everybody wants to listen and they
listen to you they're totally fixated on
everything you like - so how about how
about supervised jafari Pervez jafari
well I like the name okay he's a [ __ ] he
was an Iranian Air Force pilot and still
lives in Iran he does many lectures and
he did the famous it's the Iranian
Tehran UFO sighting he chased the UFO in
his jet and the thing turned off all the
electronics and the jet and he said this
thing was moving
how about General de Brewer well how
about David flavor I don't know him he's
um he's the guy that they were talking
about on the Bob Lazar documentary he's
he experienced something that flew
exactly like the Lazar once I'm gonna
talk to him soon movie and he incredibly
credible and you know military accolades
he's a very well-respected guy and he's
never had any other fantastical sort of
stories and he's told I can't wait to
talk to him about this yeah Ron's Jafar
he's a good guest - you should get him
oh and then there's the guy who flew
the Alaskan you know the Japan Airlines
flight with all the wine on it and the
UFOs above Alaska it circled them
several times that's a famous story I'd
get a bottle that wine yeah that was
yeah yeah so Alaska Airlines sighting
that's another one so no but I like I
like your view you are not gonna sit
here and say oh it's all true I'm
accepting it all it's too easy all I
give you all I give you to hear today
from my experience is the ones that I
believe mm-hmm and that's Betty and
Barney Hill Travis Walton Iman Josh boys
yeah Betty and Barney Hill are really
interesting one because also there
wasn't a precedent Betty and Barney Hill
in 1961 there wasn't a bunch of people
that were talking about these things
happening to them and since then they've
been very many that were really similar
very similar and it makes you wonder
because here's but this is what I want
to say to people that are skeptical and
of course I'm scared the skeptical
that's why I'm knocking holes in these
things you know but if that if it did
happen and you were left alone to try to
explain to people something that is
incredibly unique very few people ever
experience it it would be so hard to get
people to believe you well that's so I
have instructional you go to a
profession there's no such thing you
know well just somehow who can the
professional means you make money doing
it means you've studied it and you make
money doing it there's not a single
[ __ ] human being on this planet
that's a professional Explorer of other
worlds right there's not a single person
on this planet that is a professional
expert on alien civilization it can tell
you everything they need to know I know
more about French about the language of
the French language than anyone that's
ever lived knows about alien
civilizations and I don't know [ __ ]
about French do you know Sam yeah I know
it's a real place I know France is a
real place and French is a real language
and I could say Pauly vous francais
that's more than anybody can explain
about any any civilization on some other
planet gotta take the credentials of the
people who report these things and I
means barley terrestrial they are that's
right no you know UFOs generals pilots
and and on UFOs go on the record that's
Leslie Keens book and there's some
pretty pretty compelling you know
stories remember Arsenio Hall
when he
that thing you would do things that make
you go hmm hundreds in states see flying
saucers Indianapolis news you know
anyway
this is a neat book by Bruce I believe
Bruce was the real thing I believe
Stanton is the real thing
I listen J Allen Hynek is one of the
more interesting characters to me
because he ran Project Blue Book and his
directive was to debunk these stories
whether or not they were credible he was
his directive was to say that's a
weather balloon that's a that's a star
this is a swamp gas that was his
directive but then when he left Project
Blue Book he said listen these things
are real yes twenty percent of sightings
are explained and said these things are
real and when you talk to a man like
that who's living was in debunking these
things and then after it was all over he
was compelled to communicate with the
American public that there was a real
situation going yeah going on there is
and he's really interesting to man can
Arnold his sighting is pretty compelling
sure so I think I don't think they want
to form a relationship with us I think
they're coming and going like taxis and
they have been since the beginning of
the existence of life on this planet or
the existence of this planet do you
think they engineered human beings well
that mission to Mars movie is one of
NASA employees favorite movies I think
maybe the motion of Mars movie something
that's a mission to Mars Tim Robbins
really good picture doc it's a feature
feature yeah mission to Mars yeah yes it
about it's about the mission to Mars and
them discovering there was a
civilization there and that perhaps we
were helped along in our development
what year is this around ah not sure
mission two houses really really good it
was like a horror movie here's the
here's the I saw that movie Marilyn
there's a case for interplanetary
saucers that was in Life magazine okay I
remember this movie now is that a good
movie it was really good in the end Tim
Robbins kind of this new astronauts that
got really deep into UFOs right little
Adam is one of them well have an
interesting story for you and this is of
course totally anecdotally part of the
it's part of the lore and we have you
want another drink
hell yeah
okay so Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin I
do believe that we actually rent to the
moon III don't believe that I don't
believe that that's a fake experience I
know I'm gonna said people say oh well
it was black and the Dustin's
you know the just flew up and it
wouldn't it wouldn't crystal had vodka
cleanest vodka on the planet so I
believe that when and and and you know
I've Buzz Aldrin a good friend of mine
loved as a good friend of everybody's
but I loved buzz and so they go to the
moon and I love that story about there
was only 17 seconds of fuel left one
thing when they landed and then then he
had to kind of hop over some rocks to
get there you know so there's a story
that Neil Armstrong was at a conference
in in in France in a hotel room and one
and there was a woman there who had been
previously head of mi6 and she was a
part of this cocktail party and she
overheard a conversation between Neil
Armstrong and another gentleman was in
the intelligence service and I was
asking him about the moon landing and
Neil said you know there was a frequency
that we switched to to talk about other
things that were happening at that time
and then guys what do you mean he said
when we landed there on the rim of the
crater nearby he said there were several
ships and they were large and menacing
what's a menacing ship shaped like one
of your bottles of skulls well no this
is a happy school no the Coneheads
starship or mother conehead so I mean
that's a total ending I mean but I think
you know if that if you deal arm if
that's true
you know well well he only said that one
time in French maybe they again the
woman you want this will have a straight
right the woman the woman was with mi6
purportedly that's kind of a neat story
of course it's a neat story Edgar
Mitchell said that he saw something out
there too right you're Mitchell did and
he's passed Condon he's passed away
since right yeah although he was a firm
believer and the and then the STS 1979
SDS Space Shuttle footage you've seen
that STS 1979
hether satellite tether break oh I have
seen yeah the tether broke off it was a
mile long and they were supposed to spin
off a satellite it was a mile long and
they said that broke so the tether is a
mile long but in the back of the tether
you see these old lifesavers shaped
rings going back and forth mm-hmm well
David Cerreta says that's a species that
was trying to help the planet and they
were bringing giant water bags and giant
giant water vessels to heal our ozone
layer
it was the STS 1979 space shuttle tether
water heals ozone layers a lot of these
what water yeah water and water - it's a
big big massive massive dumps of water
these were supposed to be these old
shaped lifesaver shaped UFO figures and
then what he did was he compared them
against the length of the tether which
was a mile long and said these things
would have had to have been you know
quite large now that's David's arena you
should have emani's is a brilliant
ufologist and theorist hmm and sts space
shuttle 1979 and then Lonnie Zamora you
should also check and herb Shermer a
Chir Mir I'm Leslie Kean and Ralph
Blumenthal you know this is just paper
but there's a video for there you go
evidence records and plasmids in the
thermosphere there we go they're ten
separate NASA space shuttle missions
over two hundred miles above the earth
within the the thermosphere the
structures appear to be self illuminated
maybe several meters or kilometers in
size and have four distinct morphologies
what is this what's the title of this
who's this from
emeritus brain Research Laboratory
Northern California cosmology it's
pretty neat across it it may be wrong
Joseph's PhD Center for cosmology
Silicon Valley California huh the
there's but there is video video the
tether the video is weird and someone
described it as ice crystals and they
said the perspective is what's screwing
everybody up as if the ice crystals are
between us and the cable but it makes it
look like they're enormous but they're
actually quite small I think I think at
this point we can accept
that these ships are real if they're
advanced then we yes we can I think we
can accept there's just so many so much
so much footage so many reports Ted
Phillips has trace evidence so many
landing sites so many I think we'd
accept the real I think we accept these
beings are real they're many different
species some are benevolent to a summer
malevolent what we have to get past is
ok now that we know that how will that
help human transformation now John Mac
at this session I was at at this Fifth
Avenue Medical Institute a woman got up
and she said I was a socialite in
Massachusetts I all I cared about was
money and spending money and where I
could go and spend money and and buying
things in one afternoon I was in my
garden and an orange orb came into the
garden and a figure got out and lectured
me you have so much power just like the
guy in the sailboat you can make this
planet a better place your obligation
now is to use your power and your wealth
to make this planet a better place and
she is now one of the leading
environmentalists on the planet she
devotes her money and time to this
what's her name I don't know Arnie don't
remember her name but Jan Harsin Jan
Harz and I do know his name he's head of
MUFON and why is Jan Harz on an IBM X
IBM mainframe engineer a head of new
font because when he was a boy in Marin
County California he and his brother
were left for the weekend he's 10 and 12
year old brought 12 year old brother in
he was 10 an orange orb dropped into his
backyard and two beings got out and
played with them for several hours and
then he came back the next day and John
said I have to go into science I got to
know what that was that wasn't a
helicopter that wasn't it have you had
Jan on if you had yeah yeah I have Jan
on and you know should have okay should
have Jan on you should have Beverly
Trout on she's the she's the Midwestern
one of the directors for mid to the
Midwest Sam moranto the expert on the
Tinley Park cases which that is so great
I want you to retain Aykroyd has no
notes in front of them these notes are
these words just flying out of his head
these name of DC grain dismembered
Tinley Park I mean the deltas parking
above your family barbecue you know so
it's entertaining we got to get past
that they exist and get to the point
though how do we benefit our planet how
do we make this planet better how do we
take these warnings The Day the Earth
Stood Still
one of the greatest UFO movies ever oh
yeah
he comes down and he says you know these
nuclear toys you're playing with we
don't we don't like that you know so I
think that there's some intervention to
Barada nikto
Klaatu Barada nikto Patricia Neal not
sure what a great movie man that's
that's an inaugural movie yeah but you
is that have you shown your children no
not yet you should show that was in the
50s yeah that's a great one and because
it really took the real science of what
was going on and and and it took all of
the stories that were reported in
Bruce's book here and kind of distilled
them into you know into a theory of what
might be happening
hmm how much you dad you spend thinking
about this well I am an eternal
researcher and I'm always looking for
stories I love them you fond stuff
that's coming out you know my family was
into paranormal research that's why I
wrote the Ghostbusters uh my dad was a
researcher and my and his father that's
why you wrote Ghostbuster yeah because
because we have an old farm in Canada
and my grandfather was a dentist in
Kingston Ontario on the in the 20s and a
man walked up to him he had been
researching psychic research and the
other world and mediumship for many
years and a guy walked up to him and
said mister are dr. Aykroyd I believe
that I have a gift and his name was
Walter Asher's he was a locomotive
mechanic at the local engine works and
he was our family medium for for at
least ten or fifteen years and we would
have they would have seances in the 20s
and 30s and Sunday afternoon the big
dodges and Cadillacs would pull up in
the women the matrons would get out and
my great-grandfather would have a
90-minute session with the medium and
they would channel entities from the
other side have you heard of the Fox
sisters and the whole Lilydale thing the
whole mediumship of the concept that you
know we are the life billet lives beyond
what we have here do you know who John
Edwards as the the psychic on television
yeah isn't it
no busted noise well you know what
happened yeah busted with an earpiece
well he John Edwards the psychic got
busted he was he had some very well
maybe you know sometimes what happens is
they they you know they lose their
powers in they and they are unable to or
they're full of [ __ ] the entire time
that just gets like John Edwards though
I watched a show I kind of believed him
but I'm not sure if he was the one that
got busted and one of those one of those
psychics got busted yeah so
to see you across from penn jillette
yeah of course no he's like to him well
he's an expert debunk horrible yeah yeah
super skeptical
I would love I'd love to have Penn
Jillette tell me what he thinks of the
Fox sisters why why they went around the
world with a spirit that performed with
them right what happened well it wrapped
a spirit wrapped yeah well kind of ran
our AP not-not-not reading yeah yeah oh
I thought wow like muezzin reverberant
rapping ya know I'd love to I'd love to
you know so it's a spirograph mediumship
that's that's a very very telling i by
Insane Clown Posse are yeah Slipknot
there we but I I believe that we the
consciousness can survive after death
there's a school called Arthur Findlay
college in England and you can go there
and train to be a medium why you'd want
to I don't I don't know it's very
exhausting he imagine shutting down your
whole system going into and trance
reaching the other side having that
entity come through the other side use
your body yours your fluids use
everything and then abandon you after
and then just go you it's exhausting
exhausting but my family research
mediumship and I wrote Ghostbusters
based upon you know it's just our family
interest on the Fox the Fox sisters your
sisters you should get them up there's a
picture of them foxes in 1848 they were
lying in bed in their new house near
Hyde's Ville New York and all of a
sudden this kind of wrapping started
terrifying them they thought it was
confined just to that house in
Hinesville but they managed to take it
around they and when they went to
Rochester it happened in houses when
they went to a theater it happened in
front of three 400 people and they
eventually they toured the world with
this act they called it the peddler and
he was someone who was killed and
murdered and buried in the house and the
basement John Edwards a hoser here
Popoff there they are John Edwards I
looked him up it didn't come up
necessarily he was they were all they
were all and they went around the world
tipping tables and and and yeah that's a
drawing real people they never existed
no they did they did they were they were
and they were very well scrutinized
Maggie in the end of her life said no we
were we were producing we were producing
these reverberant Riley's
a head what is that is that them know
what boy said that's doubt of my realm
there's something about mean-faced
ladies from like the eighteen hundreds
of scare the [ __ ] out yeah there's the
there's the cottage there's a yeah hard
time to be alive that's the cottage that
had occurred in and you know they said
it was the ghost of the peddler that lit
that was murdered in the basement and
they look down they did find some bones
but every time they tried to build the
groundwater a dig for the bones the
groundwater kept filling up anyway
Maggie at the end of her life said no no
we were faking it I was creating the
wraps those were laggy said she was
maggie said she was faking it but she
said i was creating the wraps these
reverberate it in concert halls right
with my knees and my knuckles you know
now I can crack my knuckles maybe in my
knees but you can't make them they were
slapsies there were wrappings and then
yep and then she recanted it and said
the skeptics you know made me do it I
was talked into it there was so much
pressure on me and in the end of her
life she then recanted her recant her
retraction of it but I'm very convincing
that was the origin of spirituality
people were looking for a new religion
you had Mormonism that had come in in
the 20s you had all kinds of
Protestantism that area of New York was
called the burned-over district because
the preachers had all been through there
people who were believing in all kinds
of different religion they were looking
for something new and spiritual
spirituality and spiritualism gave them
that but you know I've had I've had
people contact me that have passed in
dreams
I've never seen a ghost I've never you
know experienced that but III do believe
that consciousness survives after death
I I do believe that it's an interesting
idea there's no evidence that it doesn't
you know I think that reincarnation is
also a fascinating concept that's
repeated in many different cultures
mm-hm and I wonder why you know there's
a great Tyler Childers song called
born-again and it's it's about things
living and dying and being reincarnated
in different times I and I think that's
very attractive to people the idea that
our physical body is one thing but the
spiritual body is something entirely
different well I think that you know
atheists and the track
it is attractive atheists are never
gonna believe that they're not going to
accept that it's hopeful it gives us a
little hope and after all you know the
Koreans they who was that they were a
Russian research research group they're
famous for the experiment where they are
the Kirlian photography K IRL I am and
you want a little zippers they they they
they photographed a woman she sat there
and she was able to blow smoke into a
fishbowl and shape the smoke in the
fishbowl so here are some Kirlian images
they have faith they photographed auras
and they did photograph they did you
know 21 grams is supposed to be the rate
of the weight of the soul and they've
they photographed a guy dying and they
claimed to have photographed his aura
leaving his body yeah yeah all these
claims is there a photograph of this
photograph I've heard I don't know of
atomic weight of the soil 21 grams and
Kirlian photo of dying man I don't know
but there you saw the auras the
photographs there why would the soul
have weight if it doesn't have a
physical embodiment
yeah well energy energy mass energy what
electricity doesn't know anyway does it
what's going well I don't know I fit
that it acts as a certain force there's
there it's certainly a force so there's
guys that's that's an interesting
question but mass is what right reacts
to scales gravity yep right I mean well
electrons you know if there's a mass
there there's an atomic mass atomic
weight any one gram seems like a lot it
does it does seem like a lot yeah fat
ass soul but but the Killians were yeah
they were they were that that would be a
fat soul yeah member they made a movie
about your into everything man you're
into ghosts you're in the Bigfoot you're
into aliens
UFO abductions everything well
it's entertaining I'm an entertainer it
isn't it you know but I feel like an
alien you remarkably sane for some noise
all these different things inside their
head I don't know my family would maybe
say not but pot you know I'm allergic to
terpenes
I love the cannabis story I beans are in
oil thought that that's it you know it's
an everything you know it's like lemon
in lot terpenes yeah we had that what
you
what if you have good pot and you're
smoking goodbye what you're smoking in
the terpene that's what makes it that's
what gives it its power Chara peens give
pot its power well it's part of the
element that contains THC well routine
it's an oil
Thirteen's is the is the is an oil
that's that that's in there and all in
all marijuana you have this you're
allergic to marijuana I'm allergic to
the terpenes the cannabinoid I my dad is
on the cannabis oil right now to go to
sleep he's 97 years old I everybody has
a dad yeah everybody has cannabis
cannabinoid receptors in them it is a
tremendously healing thing there's the
terpene there's a chart yeah cool chart
yeah beans yeah so so somehow all that
stuff yeah look up now you know and
different breeders to put something my
my parrot partner and friend Jimmy
Belushi has a farm in Oregon he grows it
and he's researching it's a dirty drug
addict it's up there selling drugs to
people pushing chugs well it's legal now
in or drugs well the point is that if
John had been a pothead he'd be alive
today sure because he died of a cocaine
and and and heroin fee ball injection he
find I had him smoking pot there that
there in the vineyard like you know back
then he would he would be alive today
yeah so I believe of comedians or pot
heads well you know wanna I hear Seth
Rogen's office at Columbia Pictures had
to BD fumed and d50 fog when he laughs
but I gave him stoner of the Year award
one day yeah when the with one of the
High Times Awards yeah I presented him
well can happen at cannabis is
tremendously valuable we're finding it
with art right if you take the THC out
and put the CBD in there that that's
great for arthritis and that I like to
smell a weed doesn't bother me it's just
it just it just bothers me as we go to
an hour just to get that cured well sure
sure so I rely on the on the on the
beverage products of your right
psychedelic experiences oh yes I've
taken acid and psilocybin and mescaline
yeah you ever had any it's some sort of
encounters while on psilocybin one of
the things that makes me more
more open to the idea of
extraterrestrials is some of the
experiences that I've had on tryptamines
you know particularly dimethyltryptamine
but also urban is that's wait
DNC goes way back for me but just like
the high school how long back is that
the DMT I mean last time it is a year
and a half in a controlled situation
yeah tell me about your experience oh
I'd be interested in oh that's a little
speedy this is a that's a DMT tattoo
that's a DMT mold oh okay yeah I got a
bunch of them there it's it's healing
for mental health they're finding that
that is it has a great effect as a
palliative profound alleviation of
anxiety there you go cuz it transforms
your perception of where you stand in
the world and it's a absolute ego
dissolver you you're you're confronted
with experiences that defied logic and
one of the things that this is
interesting one of the things that shied
me away from UFOs was DMT because
because it was so profound it was so
crazy that if a UFO landed right in
front of my house I'd be like yeah it's
not DMT though because DMT was a
completely different dimension and there
were things there then one of the things
that's you were in a controlled
environment with friends you're yes yeah
yeah but one of you seated we when
nature we seated in my houses well you
take three giant huge stuff you can shut
down your sci-fi show for talking about
aliens no no that that's right DMT has
some there's some prejudice against it
and you can opt out at the drugstore
it's in thousands of plants it's
literally in almost every plant nature
in fact the one of the universities in
Israel believes that it was responsible
for the burning bush that Moses guns in
ten commandments from yeah they think
that burning bush was actually the
acacia tree and the acacia tree is rich
in DM tenet burst into flame and he
inhaling the vapor exactly they saw God
but they think that this is just a
problem with translation is that this
what this idea of the burning bush
oh there was a burning bush well maybe
or maybe they figured out a way to
extract the dimethyltryptamine from the
acacia tree or this bush acacia bushes
well and that they took this small
amount of dimethyltryptamine from this
fire and inhaled it and had this
profound religious experience like I've
experienced like many people who
experienced that have taken it and I
think that one thing that happens when
you do this is you're confronted with
entities now I don't know what these
things are but they seem to be
communicating with you and they seem to
be talking to you and they seem to know
everything about you so the question is
like is that really your subconscious is
this is is this you know what you know
about yourself stripped down to some
very bare raw form and then confronted
with the psychedelics that perturb your
your visual cortex so they provide you
with all these intense visualizations or
is it a chemical portal to another
dimension there's were they effulgent
beings like being the way I described
means they're complex geometric patterns
made out of love and understanding
mm-hmm and that the communicating sounds
like you know HP Lovecraft was a
wonderful writer and and he describes in
my machine
no that was HG Wells by HP Lovecraft he
wrote the Lulu the the dunnage horror
and books about Cthulhu and he be kind
of you know walked out of his life and
disappeared from his family and all that
but he go uh well he can I went out for
cigarettes and kinda never came back but
no one ever found him well no I think
they found him but he had vanished for a
while HP Lovecraft maybe look up a grave
or sighs but but you know he wrote about
geometric shapes he wrote about
interdimensional geometric shapes and
and getting to a space where you saw the
universe in terms of geometry and
diamond-shaped things and multi not you
know multi patterns and colors and you
know the artist Alex gray - I don't
Alex Grey's a beautiful artist I mean an
amazing amazing guy and he all of his
stuff is tryptamine based artwork pull
up some Alex gray stuff so he could see
it it literally when you see it you go
oh and that I
recognize that I recognized that how
long was your voyage all of them are
about 15 minutes to 20 minutes long
depending upon this is all Alex gray
star beautiful yeah pull up the one with
that one down on the very bottom in the
middle the whoa yeah look at that that's
very similar to what it feels like when
you do dimethyltryptamine Alex has had
drops a little purple barrel right now
and just look at that I'd have a nice
afternoon
yeah well a lot of the things the most
profound psychedelic experiences are the
the compounds they mimic normal human
neural chemistry mm-hmm like
dimethyltryptamine is it's a natural
occurring compound in the human brain
it's produced by your liver your lungs
and there's a lot of evidence at least
in mammals it's produced by your pineal
gland which is literally your third eye
that is that's right I did DMT way way
back I think I was in high school or
something
whoa you know something and I think I
was out of motorcycle ice race or
something about doing it so that was
psycho ice race and DMT yeah living on
the edge in high school man yeah well
that's what they you know motorcycle ice
racing you get that you get on a small
bike like a Jawa sees a and you put the
metal rims with that with the studs and
then you race around the ice I never did
it but I saw it and I think I was that's
when I went to my a my my my friend said
they take one of these will have a
better time so I didn't see any beings
but well the race was fun take one how
orally how did you take it uh he said it
was a pill was a cap oh that doesn't
work no yeah yeah well no you need to
freebase it CT is all right your body
possesses a cap he'd give it to me in a
[ __ ] like the size of a horse cap right
maybe it was horse drank and I never
know he said it was the empty it's not
well if it was it doesn't work because
your body produces mono a mean oxidase
and the only way that DMT works orally
is if you take an MAO inhibitor this is
what ayahuasca is by do ya see ayahuasca
is what the the indigenous people the
Amazon to figured out is how to take DMT
with harm me
from the plants right and harmine is a
naturally-occurring MAO inhibitor so
that's how you could take it orally it's
also why the experience is not as
intense but it's longer and many people
find it more spiritual because you can
relax Jimmy's going to the experience
done later yeah but it's not in a
capsule form you were did he dosed you
up with someone else oh yeah I don't
know yeah no I guess I've something yeah
who knows that could have been suicide
well psilocybin converts in the body to
something very similar to DMT the DMT is
the chemical compound is N and D
dimethyltryptamine but something happens
in the body's production of DMT or the
body's breaking down of DMT where it
produces something called for forelock C
and M dimethyltryptamine this is out of
psilocybin so maybe he gave you
psilocybin pills now just real common
that's real could be but it usually if I
were to take psilocybin I D D time I
just eat the mushroom yes a lot of
people take him in capsule form though
so they can get an exact dose remember
sprinkling it on my cereal once and why
it's yeah and then going to deliver the
mail yeah my friend took him in peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches Bowl
psilocybin and then I went and picked up
my mom mail truck and yeah I was I was a
Royal Mail courier that was an
interesting morning did you get
everybody's mail oh yeah this is fast
[Laughter]
but that's one of the things that made
me more open to the idea of
extraterrestrials but more closed off to
the ideas of these stories that people
tell because I felt like these stories
that people tell were so crude it was
almost like they were trying to fact
simulate this real experience they were
trying to recreate it in their mind and
the other thing about these abduction
experiences is that almost all of them
happen at night and a lot of them happen
while people are asleep and during sleep
is when they believe your body's
generating dimethyltryptamine they
believe that DMT is also responsible for
dreams but you know the Linda Katya case
pretty compelling she comes out of the
apartment she's grabbed by an orange orb
and then when was this this was in the
evening early on and that's a thing that
night but there were two witnesses from
the Brooke
our witnesses from the Brooklyn Bridge
to United Nations security and a judge
in New York state judge that saw the
whole thing they saw her being abducted
a saw her being slipped sucked through
her window into the ormond wants to the
really river yes my pendant Lee they
told the same story they were no they
were together in the car and they saw it
and I'm not judge a New York state judge
sought he's independent he's independent
so he came forward as well once once it
started to come out and these two guys
went to the apartment where Linda lived
I wasn't a real name and of course she
was freaked out that someone would come
in and talk to chief there was a while
before they were able to get her to talk
about it it is possible the thing about
it is that if these were unique
occurrences that only happened once
every 10 years or something like that
very rarely and it did happen and you
were left with this memory in this this
thing go try telling it to people that
haven't experienced it good luck good
luck it nice to believe you you need
people just like you experienced trauma
or car accident yeah it'll around you
who love you to listen to the UN yeah I
believe you don't want to help you right
now and ruffle is a lady who helps with
abductees and there's a you know there's
there's some psychiatrists who deal with
it you know yeah yeah well it's it's a
that's the John Mac thing right John Mac
who was a psychiatrist and he was a very
pragmatic reasonable person and started
these he was dealing with these people
that were having these traumatic
experiences and he was trying to break
them down I believe it was hypnotic
regression there was the initial tool
right and through that he sort of sort
of started piecing together these people
independently had remarkably similar
stories right was a him obviously
was it hypnagogic just 320 million
people in this country alone if 100
people have these experiences good luck
getting those other 390 million people
listen to you they're not gonna listen
to you this is why I'm I've tried to be
open-minded I think if you went out to
the local mall and when said do you know
the UFO is yes have you ever seen one no
the only buddy who's ever seen one yes I
think you if you went to the eye
to the outer perimeters there is perhaps
you yeah it's perhaps no and that's look
that's the important except I'm on like
Michael Shermer and other people and and
Philip class they come on and they try
to debunk these UFO stories but they
don't have their facts straight they
don't they don't haven't done the
research they haven't studied these
cases they come and they just blank it's
a it's it's not real Michael has never
met a conspiracy that he doesn't want to
debunk mm-hmm right do I think that
recently he came out with was that he
thinks that Jeffrey Epstein might have
been murdered I was like whoa how yeah
yes such so far table ranger believe no
but it has to go that far yeah it has to
go that far where a guy is on suicide
watch and they go ad don't try to kill
yourself again and then leave him in the
jail cell at him that kind of kind of
let him do what he wanted I think I
think they'd let him I think they'd let
I tell himself I think they more the
money let him they let him or they might
have killed them he had a broken neck
mmm that's true that's yeah it's true
that's right when you get justice fixie
ation that's right that's right yeah
yeah well if anyone deserved to die that
mo foo did yes
yeah if everyone's telling the truth I
believe you're right yeah it's the whole
story of UFOs is so interesting it's so
interesting because the Fermi paradox
because this concept that if there are
these species that exist in this
infinite number of stars and infinite
perhaps even infinite number of
universes we really don't know our
limited perception of what the the
actually multiverse yeah physicists
refer to all the time Neil Tyson will
refer to the multi started happily and
comfortably well he also will refer to
the concept that not only is the
universe infinite but what infinity
truly means is the real version of
infinite is not just it's really big but
it's that it's so big that there are an
infinite numbers of dan Aykroyd Joe
Rogan's and Jamie Vernon's in a room and
there's an infinite number of versions
of this conversation that we're having
about
right there was a philosophy died of
philosopher a few years ago he believed
that everything that you think like if I
think okay I want to go steal a Cadillac
well in another dimension I've stolen
that Cadillac and I've done that yeah
you know and he was he believed that
everything we think can become reality
in another dimension and does become
reality it's there's so many different
possibilities it's it's impossible for
our puny little brains to wrap our heads
around I had Nick Bostrom on who's a
philosopher who was famous for his work
on simulation theory and the concept of
artificial intelligence and sentient
artificial intelligence and he was
freaking me out yesterday this the where
he was talking about essentially it's
more probable that you are in a
simulation than you're not a simulation
I'm so hard looking around your studio
here on this play I was this is a
simulation I mean I you I will not
divulge what I saw in this incredible
warehouse here but the greatest gym I've
ever seen the greatest workout space
well I feel like my whole life doesn't
make any sense of my life if anybody
should believe in a simulation it should
be me
yeah no I I'm in a wonderful simulation
here today oh this is great yeah no look
you know a human experience it's just
wonderful how we wake up in the morning
human identity yeah you know the
electric love love just our ability to
communicate our ability to see friends
and the beautiful feeling you gets when
you hug affairs it just pheromones is it
just chemical is this anymore yeah
that's right and love was what you
should drive us we are here to give and
receive love and once we figure that out
and the world's going to be a lot better
we have to if you don't know that
everything else is horseshit you can
have a hundred million dollar house and
a private jet and if you know of love
you don't have anything you're missing
the key ingredient that's right you know
it's like having cement but not having
water that's right you know it's right
you have you have the mix but you know
the water yeah you have nothing yeah you
ain't building any house [ __ ]
yeah I know and and you know we and
unfortunately there's so much lack of
love in the world for other other you
know and there's so many people that
want to instead of propagate love they
want to propagate anger
and they want to propagate hate and it's
so easy to do and so many people are
dissatisfied by their own existence that
they want to do that but they don't
understand but that by doing that you
are perpetuating this whole terrible
cycle that you've been caught up in
yourself if you go out there hating on
everybody and being shitty to everybody
and throwing all this anger out there in
the world that you are literally
poisoning yourself there's a there's a
wonderful quote about jealousy that I
think also applies to hate is that it's
one of the the rare things that is
ineffective on the person who's your
target but works on you instead
mm-hmm you're jealous here's a person
out there like oh I I wish I was living
her life and you're angry at her like
you it's not hurting her it doesn't even
affect nobody's like you dancing in the
wind you feel the poisonous you person
to win that way it's gonna come right
back on you it's just hard for people to
understand that there's techniques and
there's strategies and there's
philosophies that can help you steer
through this world with a happier life
and that that is a big part of it a big
part of his embracing love and
friendship and camaraderie and be nice
to people and I think it's much easier
to be nice and to be mean yeah it's hard
for some people because they're not even
nice to themselves well self-love is
where it all starts
yeah I don't like yourself you ain't
gonna do too well yeah anybody else and
you know sometimes I wake up in the
morning like myself or what I've done
the neck the day before or in the past
but you know in the end I yeah I gotta
love myself enough to get up and get
going and yeah just don't keep going it
too much this wild crystal vodka no no
everything in moderation hey can you
fall in love with a vehicle I brought
you a Scott man I brought you hemmings
mate or motor news you know this book
can't read that thing I'll go crazy and
start buying no no that's like me too
but what's your dream car like I know
you've got that beautiful Land Rover up
there land cruiser I have a lot of cars
what like if you what what yeah what
yeah what kind of cars you like I mean
well I love American muscle cars those
in my favor okay yeah I'm sixties those
are my favorite like dodges and I have a
65 Corvette that I love to death I have
a 69 Nova that's being built oh yeah my
friend uh Nova
my friend at a 494 degree that was great
he had a Camaro 454 Camaro nice yeah
that was fun man I just think there's
something that happened during the 1960
yeah there was like this this incredibly
potent moment in the universe where this
part of the world he iack oka well not
just Lee Iacocca because that was
Chrysler it was also Ford and it was it
was Chevy there was but the Mustang was
Lee yeah yeah yeah yeah but Leslie
Chrysler know he started with the
Mustang but he went to Christ or no the
muscle cars of them s Thomas Lee
Iacocca's right that's the super bee and
the shaadi yeah Sheldon Carroll Shelby
the Super Bee that was so much there was
so much fun those are Cudas those
barracudas yeah me but this but the the
point to me is that there was something
that happened during that time with
American automobile manufacturers
working they had come up with designs
and they were influenced in a way that
they created these iconic images that if
you looked at a 1960s car those 1960s
cars are so incredibly valuable and
cherished where as late 1970s in 1979
car nobody gives a [ __ ] about that car
like in 10 years the cars went from
being amazing to [ __ ] the 70s were
pretty bad for automobile cities - they
hit up blip they have especially
American muscle cars they hit this blip
and then during this blip they created
Camaros and Dodge Chargers and Shelby
gt500 s they just had with the young
people bought into and loved and now
today you can't get a young person to
even go to in a showroom the people who
are listening to your your your show and
I would say 80% of them they're in taxis
or uber or buses they don't care about
cars interesting right people live in
New York City I have friends who live in
Manhattan they born and raised didn't
even know how to drive all my kids
didn't get their licenses till they were
in their 20s here's a 1969 Dodge Dart
GTS they want 77 grand for it that's
they're very valuable I know they're
really really valuable are you doing
with that magnet why'd you bring that
because I know you love cars III want to
give it to you yeah
any cars Oh sir sir um haha too much got
my father got me into this you know so I
think my favourite like my favourite car
that I have is a 1932 Pierce Arrow 1604
limousine this is the car that and it's
been untouched I basically found that in
a barn and I've never touched it the
Pierce arrows were built between 1908
and 90 million with that all the Pierce
Arrow a pierce-arrow museum Buffalo New
York piee RC 69 Pierce I know it's 3232
oh ok so lay off so Pierce Arrow made
cars between 1908 and trucks and
bicycles between 1919 38 1938 they've
got bought by Studebaker what happened
in the 30s they began to build these big
luxury coaches in the 30s in the
depression to compete with Packard and
rolls-royce and rampage and all the
other big companies that were out there
the white house always had pure serous
white house motor fleet will show the
Pierce arrows on the Pierce Arrow is
beautiful because it had you know the
Bullitt headlights that are on most old
cars from the 30s the Pierce Arrow has
the headlights fused into the fender
like sculpture you see there they are
you see how the the other fender is
fused in it's like part of the car and
so I have a 32 1604 rj edgar Hoover had
those that's like Bonnie and Clyde type
car oh yeah no I need this office I need
the tops and auto of you know 100-round
drum you know third does anybody take
one of those and put like a modern
suspension many times but I've kept mine
original it's never been touched you see
the way the headlights are fused right
into the eye so I have a 32 it kind of
looks like that it's green all people
and up and yeah they're pretty cars so
that's that's my kind of those are
pretty but they don't resonate with me
well I like it's a v12 it's an Allison
v12 the same engine that they had me and
these p-51 Mustangs it doesn't mean that
I don't appreciate it it's like I don't
have any I don't lust for them yeah a
1971 barracuda I lost this yeah that's
in there yeah get excited so I like that
carve a little Bentley a little 48 mark
six Bentley it's got an overhead valve
six in it it was built at the end of the
war you know to kind of get England back
into production I liked that car but my
regular everyday driver
and this will be completely boring to
most people on the planet I have a 2011
Ultimate Edition Mercury Grand Marquis
luxury sport four-door sedan okay that's
like what's that
the New York Times said when when the
production of the of the big Fords were
discontinued the big Grand Marquis when
they were discontinued in 2011 they went
out of the out of the out of business
they stopped making them the New York
Times said you've always liked one but
you never really wanted one
well I found two of them in upstate New
York and they used to be and they I
found them and I looked I was driving in
Auburn New York Anna and and and I saw I
was whipping by in this town on my way
down and I saw these two cars sitting
there with snow and I looked I liked
that Grand Marquis so I found out about
them bottom found out they were both
equipped by the US State Department
motor pool for diplomatic career they
had lights and sirens in him and they
had work done on the motors I'm on the
401 in Toronto a Mercedes you know 300 C
will pull up behind me and won't like
want me to move over and say okay
geriatric driver and the old Marquis
move over and I just go and I'm gone
with this thing that big v8 no chip in
it there it is that's it that's my car
yeah that looks like a government car
thought I'd check my paperwork yeah know
that and that's got the beautiful minor
black and it's got the beautiful v8 and
it's got the engine works and that's my
regular drivers drive one of those and
it's just total sleeper totally yeah I
pull up the lights to Corvette so look
at them and I'm like take them no
probably in that thing nothing there
that's funny yeah I love the old
Packard's in that so you like the muscle
cars yeah I'm Lauren Tesla Tesla t-shirt
yeah I got one out there oh they're
beautiful oh I love that guy what a
visionary what a man man I mean come on
he went to Queen's University in my
hometown
yeah and Kean Kingston Ontario Canada
Penitentiary capital of the country
he went to Queen's University which is
like your Harvard or read or
Yale and he went there for two years so
whenever I've never met a LAN but I'm
gonna sit down and talk to him both
those Kingston winter he's a great guy
yeah his car is the most preposterous ly
fast car I've ever driven in my life
what seems right stupid
well the doing the thing that I have out
there I have a Model S Oh elite 100 d oh
yeah it is the most ridiculous car I've
ever driven it makes other cars feel
dumb I have other cars that I enjoy
because I love engineering I love cars I
just love them I've always loved them
since I was a kid but that Tesla makes
them all look stupid they're all dumb
that car goes zero to 60 in two point
four seconds and makes no sound it
transcends it just moves through space
and time in a different way
punches a hole through through the life
itself it's show me no brilliant it's
there it's just one I had a friend who
had one in Toronto that's a no and he
took me yeah we shouldn't lick it up I'd
give you the keys to mind there's after
yeah no they don't drive we have drivers
today no they zapped through that yeah
you need to drive one you need to drive
mine you know my wife would love one
because she loves you know she's an
environmental activist and now she needs
to get one the problem is that she loves
her laptop so much that if that big
screen in the uh-huh Tesla yeah that big
screen yeah I think she'd be on that
more than map well I know there's done
that thing but Hames you can plan on
when you part know when you're when
you're driving to know at a park we
won't let's do it but the guy have my
friend he has a Tesla there in Toronto
there and he said he he he programmed it
in downtown Toronto and it drove him to
Kingston city hall and parked in from
the city hall didn't even have to look
at look at he was working on his laptop
Todd well that guy's an [ __ ] you need
to look kids jump in front of your car
you need to be well yeah yeah I guess
that's where too much reliance on that
you need you definitely I mean that's
what other vehicles do you have a 69
Camaro oh yeah I have
2007 Porsche 911 you like you like a
high-performance car that's what I got
with that Ford that I'm driving it's
just it's just beautiful yeah yeah I
just love I just love cars
a la I've always loved them they're one
of my favorite things in life I like
looking at them I like I've watched
videos on cars even if I'm not even
interested in buying them yeah I just
love them no no it's true wonderful I
love the Duesenbergs man there's two
great museums there's the Auburn Cord
Duesenberg Museum in Auburn Indiana
have you been to Jays garage yeah yeah
my one of my cars was on Jays garage
okay yeah 65 Corvette was on how great
of guys he's great he's one of the best
well I think I told him I was like you
are so much happier and more more
interesting when you're talking about
cars yeah you ever were when you were
hosting the Tonight Show he's a great
host of The Tonight Show but The Tonight
Show is basically who are running a
commercial for other people's records
best yeah for their movies their
television shows that they have coming
out and you're there to sort of be the
entertaining guy and he was wonderful at
it how by he's way better I love the
military the old dump our wagons fuel
dodge power wagons what kind of trunk do
you have I live on a farm so I have to
go for truck so I have that 95 Toyota
Lane oh yeah out there and I also have a
71 Ikon Bronco
oh yeah that's out there too you can
whip through the desert on those yeah I
think one of the greatest cars being
made now is the Lincoln Navigator the
new oh yeah it's amazing God I mean
that's enough once I may I used to have
the Ford Excursion that was the greatest
car ever built by man have the aviator
now - it's a smaller version they're
sensational cars those really are
navigators the new ones they put the
Escalade to shame they really do I don't
like other brands but amazing they're
gonna come out with a new one
Escalades are amazing but when you get a
navigator like whoa this is next-level
it is next-level speaking of cars there
was a great old Cadillac and once upon a
time in Hollywood did you see oh yeah we
were talking about the other day I think
yeah black no no no I have it I met him
at the comedy store though this is one
of the great film like this is amazing
Gus is gonna win Best Picture
I'm a member of the Academy are you mind
you yes of course yes on
I think you voted on you you know you
regret no not really I support my people
in the industry that I can tell you
right now and I'm gonna get in trouble
for this that that's my vote for best
picture right now really what a superior
look at that beast yeah that old cattle
that's an amazing car man and how great
are those performers I can't wait for a
Brad Pitt's new movie ad astra to come
out the new space movie that he's doing
Alex how great were those two guys in
that film how great was that cast
everything was superb film inking and if
you know the Madsen story it's all that
what's so well I don't want to give any
spoilers no that's not but it's it's one
of those movies where you think
something's gonna happen and it's
something entirely more magical happens
yeah Brad Pitt is like just supreme
those design are DiCaprio's I know that
always but this is this yeah these are
masters yeah and I love to watch them
work i I love I'm not in the pictures so
much anymore we've got the Ghostbusters
movie that we're working on now and I
will be have to be performing in that
but I what is the deal with the new
Ghostbusters movies so they're really
good there was the one with all girls
great and film in the really good film
those girls were superb but I should
have been sitting there as a producer
watching costs a little more I you know
Paul Feig and and I and Ivan we had our
little conflicts there were things that
we thought that we didn't think would
work why shoot it why spend the money
but you know he's a director you got a
we'd have to have faith so there was a
little conflict there and I've spoken
about it before but all that's in the
past I think he made a great picture
with the girls I I love it I think
they're all great in it really you know
he treated the movie with with a tribute
kind of legacy respect and and there
were some great new spirits in there and
the girls were great now Ivan Reitman
son Jason has written a new movie called
the goat balls going to be ghostbusters
the third movie that he's run away now
well it'll be all most of the original
people and then the Rihanna stars first
movie
yes some from the original memories
gonna be in it we're we're we're hoping
come on bill yeah we're hoping come on
yeah and then the new the new cast and
it's it's the new cast as well there
they are younger you don't throw Bill
Murray out a window and
oh yeah yeah he played he played a
psychic he played a skeptic psychic and
he played Michael Shermer Mary played
yeah through mother one that because you
would want to throw my no no no I don't
wanna throw a better window no come on a
fake window no no no I have other things
that could do that with him put them in
my old farmhouse for the night inside
buddy so yeah so that's it's gonna be
great I'm so excited about it and it's
just just wonderful to be able to you
know go back and revisit that all that
yes but I was saying I love my
colleagues I don't do the pictures
anymore much and I'm in that way my
greatest movies of all time there
because anyways collaborator films yes
for sure I had a great collaborators and
and you know I love watching people work
actors on Broadway and I love watching
actors work in film and I enjoy going to
movies it's it's just I'm into other
things as you heard there was a bunch of
comics of The Improv the other night
talking about Ghostbusters and talking
about holes others Blues Brothers still
to this days one of the all-time great
comedy films it really is yeah it's a
great movie it's just one of those
movies where it gives you this feeling
like you're just so appreciative that
you can watch it like wow we had
smocking Ray Charles and Aretha John Lee
Hooker oh yeah no everything's great in
that movie it's just great no no we had
good good times on that and it holds up
and on you know what here forty some
years after John and I first performed
on SNL Jimmy and I are still doing it we
have a concert in Minnesota coming some
maize and we still do it you know well I
figure well I can still move I'll still
dance and move and you know I'm not
gonna sing from a chair like Solomon
Burke you know do you like your real
interests though like they're spread
apart you have a lot of different things
going on like you seem to be a guy who's
got freedom and independence which is a
beautiful thing to see well I don't have
a desk job which yeah I'm happy if I
never but you're pursuing your vodka
company you're obviously I mean you're
not profiting off for this UFO research
but you're obviously balls deep in it
i-it's it's just fun because it's
entertaining and I think it's
enlightening and if people want to come
to me and get my view of it I'm happy to
present my view you know and I'm happy
to hear stories and I'm happy to hear
skeptics comes come forward and tell me
why the thing I saw when I was on my
motorcycle was not a UFO right why was
it okay it was a hydro helicopter okay
well okay if it was a hydra helicopter
why am I not hearing a rotor whop 400
feet above me what do you what's your
take on the human memory being very
fallible there's like a lot of there's a
lot of funky no question about it no
question about it you can no no I
remember I remember I wore a striped
t-shirt on that Sunday and then you look
at a picture all no it was solid black
of course you remember the tracing I
mean about these I mean how much do you
think you remember about these
experiences I remember every I remember
every detail of the sightings I've had
because they define reality every day
things that are not that profound your
memory goes no no I try I try of course
because we'd go crazy if we had to
remember everything right right that we
picked off the ground three years ago if
you had that or just today right like
what what color shirt was I wearing when
you met me you were wearing a kind of a
whitish grey kind of a corded t-shirt
and you had sweat on and okay clothes
great thermal yeah okay yeah just check
it here's some of the Cadillacs with the
fin his name was Harley Earl oh you know
the guy designed it yeah there were two
great designers one was Harley Earl yeah
and then Virgil Exner was the guy with
Chrysler and he brought in the Finn as
well but when I chose the vehicle for
ghostbusters I thought what I need the
biggest station wagon made and it's got
a fit for people in the front and it's
got to have capacity for the so I picked
the 1959 Cadillac Miller media or hearse
because it just had the capacity we
needed and then the bonus was it just
looked so good yeah what's the golden
year for Cadillac I would say 59 60 when
you had the full fin that that 59 60 fin
was just
the pin is ridiculous yeah I parked in
that guy me wedding you know why offend
one day because we was rocking time we
don't want to do that we all want to go
to the moon you know we all love the
Stars you know yeah by 1959 in actual
1959 Cadillac Jamie but that's like a
not one that was ever made I think that
was a concept car yeah wasn't a concept
car yeah no there there now you could
put three bodies in that trunk that's so
bad that's a hardtop convertible there
with the no pillar post a beautiful car
that was back when gas was 13 cents yeah
on the motor the motors were beautiful
in those cars
yeah melt like [ __ ] and if you kept the
windows rolled down you get brain damage
no look at that thing hey kudos hey to
Detroit to Detroit you bet yeah and
today Detroit's like a booming town
there's all kinds of stuff going on
new what do you think of that building
or that that mid-engine Corvette that's
pretty amazing you've seen that thing I
haven't you know for me I mean I get my
right leg might fit in that I don't
think I get big they have plenty of room
inside of them they've designed them for
taller folks you know if I could buy any
car if I could I would try it on any car
stop pretending that rich how dare you
well it's not that it's just like if I
could drive the streets and actually be
seen in a car that I felt comfortable in
it would worry about that but Lee yeah
is that why you have that crazy the
sleeper that that's a new Corvette look
at this yeah that's beautiful the
Bentley it's 2019 Jamie that's actually
a front-engine car you want to go with
2020 the 2020s a mid-engine car the 2020
is the very first there it is that's the
very first go to that red one of the top
four I win chopped with the court no
that's the old one I love him he doesn't
know jack [ __ ] I like the Bentley
Mulsanne the the big one the big Bentley
Mulsanne cruiser love that that one
right there Jamie that your cursor was
just on yeah that's it click on yeah but
click on that that's a mid-engine
Corvette it's a different car see what
is is the engine is behind the
passengers in between the passengers and
the rear wheel whereas the other ones
it's in the front trunk you see the one
in the back that
I don't I don't think you're gonna get
the average software engineer at we work
for instance wanting to buy that car
because he's taking his the bus and he's
on uber and he's in taxis they tell me
stop being a [ __ ]
now we get that yeah new Corvette is so
powerful it's warping the frame and
tests America yeah they don't even have
the zr1 or the zo6 yeah that's the
reality 51 mom yeah no I love I love
speed you know that speed kills more men
than anything it killed Santa means you
know no you're wrong no 70% of men
between 35 and 65 die from mechanical
speed jet skis yep motorcycles this is a
70% 70% died from accidents holy this is
some this is a statistic I read well
whether that's true or not we know that
we like speed so yeah watch your votes
watch your jet skis watch your
motorcycles watch your commerce my dad
that's at my age like I'm 67 now my dad
at 65 had two Buick Riviera's well to
1960s 62 63 Buick Riviera's and he got
he an e and he was down to like four
points on his license by the dyno yeah
and he loved cars do we got me into the
cars you know y'all music is one of
those cars that there was a victim in
the recession
yeah Buick Pontiac Plymouth gone yeah
yeah well sure well there's all kinds of
names we don't see anymore like
especially from the 30s you know the
Packard the grandpa the Diana moon the
REO and like the GTO Pontiac GTO is gone
you know yeah Plymouth is just gone I
mean they still have dodged so people
try to revive it the new challenger
looks pretty good it's kind of very nice
yes the Camaro the new Camaros a monster
of a car yeah III just I've always been
a fan of those rumbly engines and those
you know they just they're viscerally
exciting yeah no no I love them
absolutely yeah how about motorcycles I
don't [ __ ] with them I was about to get
one I had a bunch of took a bunch of
lesson
and I was going for my license and then
two friends wiped out well yeah and got
pretty significant accidents and one guy
that I know got hit by a car by an old
man who ran a red light and t-boned him
and sent him flying into the air and
snapped his femur no that that that
would turn you off I've been riding
since I was 19 and you ride in LA I can
ride anywhere but I prefer to ride in
the country up north in Canada you know
or I'm living these days a half and a
half here half there half there a little
more in the States because of the travel
with the ban on that but I I'm there
with my dad in Canada a lot and then we
have the old family farm but the with
the cotton farm house and I've got a
spotty well let's say let me say that
it's there's residual energy from the
people who've lived there in the past so
you hear footsteps and voices and creeks
and doors closing in that and many
people have had experiences in it so
there's a reason why people don't want
to live in a house or people were
murdered
no one was killed in that farmhouse
right many people pass there but even
that weird that weirds people out but
absolutely if you have a house where
people were murdered and this is why
there's laws you have to decide oh I had
to divulge DJ uh it wasn't because of a
murder but when I sold our house in Los
Angeles we lived in mama Casas old
estate and order Wilson Drive and she
sold it to beverly d'angelo and she's
been on the celebrity ghost show talking
about the spirits that were in that
house what happens uh you know jewelry
will hop around the table shapes will be
seen you'll feel a touch in the shoulder
that kind of thing the staff felt it and
I had an experience one night where
something got into bed with me I was
alone I don't went on there but I just
figured well in my I think I was being
come on to there but anyway Thank You
Tube clip that house Anne Aykroyd [ __ ]
that ghost
well or it did try to come on to me and
I didn't refuse its so you resist him
you know what I just dug 'old up next to
it and went to sleep
I phoned with it I did I felt a shape I
looked and saw the night scene I saw the
depression in the mattress and I felt
ashamed about that form next to me and I
I'm not I'm not no no not that night I
was working on a picture and went to bed
early
I was alone you're laying alone in bed
and you're working on a film I'm lying
there was something that I've been
working down at Universal I don't know
maybe dragnet or something like that
okay see you working on drag men living
in bed and then there's like a wait next
I feel a wait next to me I turned I like
up the person is laying
I saw the depression there were two yes
and I and there were two spirits that
might have been there maybe mama cast
herself although she died in London and
then there was another guy that
apparently a rumor was he died of a drug
overdose at a party and they buried him
in the hillside and my daughter saw him
walking with a little red-haired girl
down the hall once and and and you know
we think that he might have been there
but anyway when we sold the house to
Beverly
there was a write in the California real
estate document that we had to sign by
law you have to divulge any unusual
activity in the house so I had to sign a
Azam there that said yes at the
beginning of our tenure in the house we
did have experience yeah so she bought
the house anyway she's still there she's
very happy you had to sign papers that
said you had unusual active you sell a
house in California you will look in
every real estate contract there will be
a clause that you must report a new
unusual activity so that is the status
of state recognized what if you got
what's that
what if you do acid in the house well I
can tell you about something individual
activity well that's unusual activity
that you're doing that's not external
but that California you know just that
the state of California requires that in
their real estate documents it's it's
pretty compelling evidence that there's
something going on or compelling
evidence the people are paranoid they
want people well I think the coasts and
spirits also have have reality I think
you think so I believe so tell me about
this thing you're laying down in bed so
you're about to go to sleep sleep
everything's good and I and I feel this
depression I feel this something Anna
are you asleep yet not asleep no no I
just turned out the light and I look and
I see this
and then I go well what am I gonna do
about this I'm gonna leap up screaming
no I rolled over and I just gonna
knuckle up against it and and went to
sleep and I slept with like a baby step
like a baby so there's a scene in the
Ghostbusters movie where I'm in I'm
lying down in an old fort and then this
ghost hovers over me and in the
director's cut I think the belt comes
off and the pants come down whoa so sex
with ghosts he didn't get nervous you
know I may have been so tired I may have
been so resolved and resigned I thought
you know what there's no point in
panicking there it is yeah so that's you
do you just accept it yes that's right I
just accept it that's some way to go man
I mean why fight it it's spiritual it's
true it's true
so did you smell it no no smell just
just sense out the way felt the way and
saw the depression and then when I feel
anything on your body I did on the form
yes I did I felt a form next to me when
I knuckle dup push away I did not did
you push against I actually kind of
wanted to see what it felt like if there
was something there and I did feel
something there I was a little feminine
or masculine it felt masculine Haro you
were cuddling with a dude like a dead
biker maybe yeah I don't know it was the
guy who died in the hillside I don't
know could be well I don't want it
friendship you know this male or female
they say the old days men used to just
sleep together
they're just actually sleep sleep like
well you know there's a yes there's a
there's a at Davis and Abraham Lincoln
Lincoln yeah we're partners and they
were law partners and they slept in the
same bed many times when they were on
the road yeah I was probably cold as
[ __ ] back then it was hung about the
room that bar the world yeah
yeah I just have a couple blankets and
your stay heated together yeah so when
you woke up in the morning did you feel
crashed or violated I had slept
beautifully I woke gotten maybe better
than ever
pretty good yeah I mean I told some
people about the experience and mmm when
there were people that worked in the
house and that were there and then that
you know the live and that that knew
that was something going on but they
knew nothing of it you and a ghost had
something happening after I told them
yeah so they knew something was going on
well because they had been they've here
the Stairmaster going by itself the
exercise the exercise it apparently yeah
and and a hand on the shoulder then the
sighting my daughter had then you know
other little things like jewelry dancing
on the table we knew something was going
on in that house oh so you're a hundred
percent on ghosts I am now tell me about
why you're a hundred percent in on
Sasquatch is that that one is a that's
more puzzling time well just that it's
it's again Gabriel Reese's story was
quite convincing Jeff Meldrum's research
amazing I would have talked to her about
ya Jeff Meldrum told me he cut his
finger off said if he could find out if
Sasquatch was really take a pinkie off I
said if you cut your finger off to know
that Sasquatch is real would you do it
he was which finger I'm like your pinky
well he's got casts he's got hair I went
to Jamie Bravo
Jeff Meldrum and the ldr um it used to
be it's in my room
he's a he's uh you know he's a paling
geological scientists at the University
of South Dakota but he can also be a
silly man
sometimes study things you memorize them
you pass a test but you still silly well
but but you talk to him did you think
did you feel he was you know I open up
my finger for nobody man yeah I'm not
giving up a finger to find I have
sasquatches real that's crazy
you know yeah he's pretty devoted to it
but it's been you know yeah T the yak
and yet his story you know the Yeti
story and just the around the world it's
just the the sightings that that people
have had all right hi Greta burners well
there was a book called diary when
Alaska housewife it was about a woman
she wrote it she left in the 70s to move
from Kansas to Alaska and her husband
worked on the pipeline and she tells the
story one afternoon when she was at her
you know her window in the kitchen and
she went outside into the garden so she
felt saw something went outside and she
smelt this really strong strong musky
musky odor and she saw this big huge
shape at the corner of her garden kind
of disappear in the woods and I don't
know bear grizzly mmm no sure
could be yeah how about where are you on
chupacabra not at all I think it's
nonsense I think it's coyotes with mange
mm-hmm yeah I'm convinced yeah yeah I
mean they've they've captured coyotes
with mange that look like demons how
about Mothman that's a neat story or
[ __ ] listen let's go back to Bigfoot
let's not you don't believe those kids
yeah I think they're full of [ __ ] let's
go back the Mothman Prophecies the the
bridge collapsing yeah I mean I'm not
gonna sit here and argue on behalf of
Mothman but it's an intriguing story
because when you have multiple witnesses
like as far as the UFO I will go back to
good foot but the the aerial encounter
the the schoolchildren at the aerial
school in in Zimbabwe in the in the 90s
you know the story John Mac was working
on it no two beings landed in two
different crafts and they encountered
these school children all in elementary
school and now they've come back and
they're interviewing them now and their
adult time and it's amazing how their
story's synchronized why would all of
them conspire to make something up okay
we're dealing with two different things
the Mothman there were fourth really
credible kids there that the UFO thing
is less preposterous than anything
because we are currently sending
spaceships into orbit we are currently
sending probes to Mars we're involved
deeply involved in the exploration of
our solar system at least with these
robots and drones and things that we can
control that Dan'l all that makes a
hundred percent sense to me
Bigfoot is interesting to me because
there was a creature called
Gigantopithecus it was an enormous
primate that was a without a doubt lived
it's a real thing it was a bipedal
hominid they think it was between eight
and perhaps even ten feet tall was a
huge ape-like creature and it went
extinct and the reason why they found it
is because there was an apothecary shop
I believe it was in the 1920s an
anthropologist found a tooth in his path
carry shop in China he talked to the
people where'd you find this he
recognized it as a primate tooth they
brought him to the site where they found
it and then they started finding other
pieces they found bones that read that
seemed to indicate that this thing was
bipedal and this is something that's
accepted in the paleontological
paleontological record this is like when
anthropologists look in the history of
primates when they look at the they
think this is a widely accepted real
animal so why wouldn't it was real why
was so why did it why do you say that it
couldn't have survived and and beyond it
extinction and exist today in some form
it could no there's no evidence that's
compelling just like there's a famous
fact they think the only mammoths pretty
much the film
yes fake the Patterson footage yeah
that's why they say it's faked here's
the thing if it looks like a man in the
suit no animal looks like a man in a
suit there's not a [ __ ] single
correct kangaroo out there that can it
looks like a person in a kangaroo suit I
just I just think Gabriel story
Meldrum's research of the book that I
read of the woman was what was Gabriela
Reese's story well she was in the
camping up there in one of those
northern states Washington and I believe
she has video footage of Muhammad
shaking shaking though she's shaking the
shaking the shaking the motor home that
they were in yeah yeah hmm she was quite
excited to tell me the story and and
quite vivid about it she said that it
was it was if there was a small popular
try finding a Wolverine yeah try finding
or a or or a super one of these super
sloths in the you know South American
jungle now these big sloths yeah they
think they're real there's one there's
one scientist that is literally risked
his reputation and he's his whole [ __ ]
credibility's and demise because he
decided that he was going to spend his
life looking for the giant sloth and
these indigenous people have pointed him
in the right direction and they've
recognized that there's you know there's
dung that seems to be sloth dung that
they've found and they're trying to
point him towards where these things are
and the giant sloth was a real creature
but there's no real evidence that the
giant sloth is currently alive but the
thing is the vast wilderness of the
Amazon rainforest is so impenetrable it
would be like trying to walk across the
earth and make a good audit of all the
creatures that are on it yeah I got to
run into them and you know we many
species are dying on this planet right
now for dirt forest reasons but there
are many that are being discovered we
never even knew about before and you
know the northwestern forests are pretty
impenetrable to the yes Washington's
voice interesting is that the the
location of the area where if the thing
crossed the Bering Land Bridge and it
came into the United States that's
exactly where it would be mm-hmm it
would be in that Pacific Northwest
because there's no as you walk down from
Alaska we've heard the stories of
loggers going in there and seeing them
more sensing them more you know because
they're being driven out of their
environment there's a hostile accident
logging companies that they think have
been perpetrated by by you know those
yeah by the Sasquatch yeah nobody wants
to believe in Bigfoot more than me I
work I worked up in in the Northwest
Territories I was a flex track system
mechanic on Tundra crawlers and I was a
road surveyor when I was a kid I work
for the Department of Public Works and
we were up there and along them the
Hannie River the headless river where
explorers would go in and they'd find
their heads and then never come back
that can be walk by yeah the Bigfoot
heads no no just the human has a human
the headless Valley the headless River
in the honey River in a haan and I but
when I went up there and was with the
survey people there had been guys who've
been up there you know you know years
before me and they and they said that
Sasquatch was a common thing that was
spoken about among the natives and among
the survey crews out there
you ever see the Bobcat Goldthwait movie
Willow Creek no outstanding moving cat
goats we've made a horror movie about
Bigfoot
Bobcat Goldthwait the comedian made an
excellent
horror movies that it's like like like
fire in the sky that's a good depiction
you would love it oh I love it it's
about a bunch of people that go up there
to try to replicate the Patterson
Bigfoot film sort of as a lark
oh they go up there for fun and they
encounter a real sasquatch so Willow
Creek it's called yes it's really good I
love that that is a 100% believer uh-huh
he believes he and I have had some
ridiculous conversations about it be
nice to go and go into the intense woods
up there and maybe camp for a weekend
yeah look mando to see something like
that a bipedal hominid that has avoided
detection for hundreds if not thousands
of years to be amazing yeah but the
Native Americans his Native Americans
had more than a hundred different names
between all the various tribes a hundred
different names for sasquatch because I
really yeah yeah yeah
oma was one of them you know that you
saw that American world from London
thing that is uh the the guy who created
that what it pat rob a Coeur
no no that's brick Baker Baker I'm sorry
yeah Pat Magee who's the special effects
guy created the one for me but Rick
Baker designed it originally but he made
a Pat Magee me in a movie called ol mob
what was it called oma primal scream see
vegan but it's basically a horror movie
about sasquatch and you know it's it's
incredibly compelling to people like
this enormous primate that's been
avoiding detection living in the forests
legends among the indigenous people say
that they they sometimes grab children
and take them I think that's because it
used to be a real thing that's what I
think I think that's because if we all
agree and scientists agree that this
Gigantopithecus was a real thing if that
is the case then it's entirely possible
that one point at one point time human
beings were in direct contact with them
on the regular basis and those stories
been passed down through generations
every generation the real questions are
they still here because the people that
are telling you these stories like when
we talk about people in North America
it's widely accepted that most Native
Americans they share a lot of genetics
of people from Siberia because Siberia
is what's close to the Bering Land
Bridge I'll come down these people
eventually many many many many many
thousands of years migrated into America
and they have so those are people that
would have been in contact a hundred
thousand whatever years ago but they
don't know
they know that these teeth that they
found from Gigantopithecus indicate that
it at the at least a hundred thousand
years ago they were alive mm-hmm does
that mean they were alive fifty thousand
years ago very possibly like a homo
florensis you know that the Hobbit
person that I found yeah this tiny
little thing and right right on the
Flores Island that thing they didn't
even know that was real until the 2000s
and that thing existed as recently as I
think it was thirteen or fourteen
thousand years ago which is incredibly
recent yeah and this is a completely new
discovery that people found that there
was a totally different species of human
being that was very small with a chimp
sized brain but it was human it used
tools and it lived amongst humans yeah
so this thing if they know it lived a
hundred thousand years ago could have
easily lived 50 mi to live 20 so it
lived 20,000 years ago today we just
gotta go and find yeah but this there's
no evidence of mammoths either yeah
right we know they were real but there's
no like if someone said I saw a man with
you like where do you have a picture no
no but I sensed it the [ __ ] out here
with your sense of NamUs I think if you
did if you put unmount mounted a
horrible avatar style military let's say
incursion into some of the deep woods of
Northwest America you might you might
get traces but what a horrible thing
that would beat it to be an excellent
thing we get footage I know but then
you're destroying theirs Oh mom that's
Pat McGee's version of oh it's great
yeah it's like kind of like Groot and
now yeah wow that's just a weird picture
no that's beautiful um primal rage mmm
yeah look at the animatronics yeah see
that face right there Jamie yeah that's
not coming out or is it it's been out
now for quite a while a primal rage and
and I'm get it the creek is really
interesting because Willow Creek is like
Blair Witch style yeah it's all like
found footage I got whole thing like
okay here we are we're in the woods
you'd like it
Bobcats a genius is he did a great job
with it
it's really good it's like compelling
it's exciting and even if I don't
believe in Bigfoot or don't don't
believe it's currently alive just I know
too many people that are in the woods
all the time I know too many people that
are hunters that are in the woods but
how they spend weeks and weeks in the
woods and none of them seen chef they
see bears walking on two feet though
that's really normal yeah yeah and when
you're in thick dense forest bears
walking on two feet you see them in the
dusk
sure oh my god I saw Bigfoot I'm
convinced yeah and then you really are
convinced so then you go back and tell
everybody yeah I think you know
basically just each individual has to
make their own minds up about all of
this stuff and if you want to believe
it's just like your religion you know I
believe in mediumship I believe in the
afterlife of our consciousness and
that's kind of my religion and who's to
say why should I be disputed on that you
know how do you believe I'm glad as
people I want that's intelligent people
that believe in silly [ __ ] well you know
look you know many people live in the
Virgin Mary scaffolds and and that's
quite a myth and many believe in the
angel Moroni and the gold plates and the
magic spectacles and and many believe in
Zanu you know the Scientologists belief
so yeah I'm not gonna go and say hey oh
I dispute your belief there were no
golden spectacles or there were no gold
and no there was no Xenu no there was no
Virgin Mary no I respect people's belief
and they realize that's what you believe
and that's what helps you for you you
know and I I would never dispute that
and likewise I I want to be just
respected for my belief in spiritualism
and mediumship and I think there's
there's a religion and skepticism as
well I think there's this there's a that
go for yeah but there's you know I'm
saying that there's a tendency to just
try to dismiss everything mm-hmm as
being as like well believe the official
story of every single you know why
that's good because that empirical view
will be able to sort out the fake stuff
the hoax stuff from the real stuff if
people of real scientific minds and
unreal you know and quests they're go
into it
that's what's gonna that's what's going
to sort out what's real and what isn't
yeah dan Aykroyd you're a beautiful
human being thank you for being here man
Oh fun pleasure
was really pleasure 19:52 you a full
books yours and the Hemings motor you
lose is yours thank you and thank you
for the vodka that's awesome vodka yeah
tell everybody what you could buy this
everywhere right yeah everywhere there's
this we'll have the main thing about it
no additives we don't put the flavor
packages in no glyceride no terpenes no
sugars at all it's a spring clean and as
you saw you had a nice discus it's very
very really as with or without an bar
chefs love it because it's the virgin
canvas I've never been in Slovakia again
how about that well thank you very much
I love that I love that well we'll have
to have to make sure that we yes and
take care thank too much Dan Akroyd
ladies and gentlemen bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]